foreign
[Music]
go back
welcome
foreign
[Music]
City Lights
thank you
[Music]
foreign
check it out
[Music]
right
foreign
[Music]
see you
thank you
welcome welcome Chess World to another
state of chess.com it has been a minute
this is our end of year show our quarter
four show and it's a pretty big show we
got a lot in store before we get into
that for those who don't know this show
is also your chance the community to
sound off it's my favorite show I feel
like it's the show where we get to get
into all those questions that come up in
chat throughout the year while we're
doing chess commentary and we can't
focus or or fully digress into a side
topic about the future of Chess events
or strategic stuff or products and
features but that's what this show is
this is the show where we get into all
of those topics and more and so many of
you have been kind of waiting what is it
what are these big announcements what is
today going to bring to the Chess World
and on that note
let's go ahead and bring up our run a
show here that's right right at the top
of the list you kind of knew it you kind
of guessed it some of you who follow it
know that chess.com's acquisition of the
play Magnus group is official while that
may seem like yeah duh to you it's
actually been a lot there's been a lot
going on and it means a lot for what
we're going to be now allowed to talk
about and getting into we have been two
separate companies for the last six
months even if you didn't think so and
now we really get to get excited
together as little little chess kids and
talk about all the fun things that we're
going to be doing next year
and there will of course be a lot of
specific announcements with that too uh
probably one of the biggest ones for
those tuning in here is what's going to
happen to the future of the events right
the champions tour and all that that was
chess.com's Global Championship all the
things we do no longer will those be
separate what are the specifics of that
and what are our goals going forward
what does it mean for the players and
the fans that's going to be a big topic
the Magnus Carlson interview everyone
has circled right so if you're doing
nothing else you will definitely be
tuning in to hear what Magnus has to say
not just about this deal but about a lot
of things we got some questions prepared
for him and and he's going to talk about
the future of his career and the future
of what he sees uh for the game online
and for these companies of course we're
going to get specific about some of the
chessable and chess.com product
integration features for those watching
this show we tend to know we have a very
motivated a very dedicated chess
audience because you're tuning into this
show on a Wednesday morning when you
should be working so by definition if
you're here you want to hear what we
have to say about jessabola chess.com
and we're going to talk about about a
lot of things with that and then if you
missed the memo
we crossed 100 million members there's
actually a big announcement that we're
going to do to celebrate that with tons
of giveaways to fans and a huge event
coming uh in quarter one of 2020 to be
to celebrate it and finally we will of
course be uh be ending the show with an
AMA as we always do where someone asks a
question they poke the bear Danny Danny
sounds off PR tells Danny later you
shouldn't have said that but we do it
anyway we do it every show and it's a
ton of fun so make sure you tune in for
the AMA at the end of the show but all
right
we've set the table I hope I hope that
you're ready everybody and and gonna
stay with us all day we've uh we
mentioned at the top of the list that it
was the acquisition that went through
finally
um and two guys who probably worked
harder than anybody to help bring that
to life are going to be joining us uh in
just a second I'm gonna I'm gonna bring
up a kind of a board for us to get
through as we talk to the two respective
CEOs about what this actually means that
we formally acquired the play Magnus
group what does it mean for the better
opportunities for the Chess World and uh
all the other things that we want to do
together so
on that note I think we should bring him
in let's bring them in they're uh you
know them you love them they are the
CEOs respectively of chess.com uh Eric
olivest and Andreas Tomei are now with
us guys so happy that you're here Eric
I'm gonna throw it to you first and and
say you have to pick one because I want
to balance this here you're not allowed
to say the 50 things you're excited
about what is one of the things you are
most excited about that we are we've
gotten this over the line to start doing
things together with the play Magnus
group
I'll just say as a fan seeing uh Hikaru
and Magnus face off on the speed Chess
Championship as as we did uh earlier my
my greatest dream already came true uh
so hopefully a lot more of that I'm
super excited to see that and here and
and watch more just amazing top level
chess uh seeing all the the the the tour
and Championship come together
um and all the events going forward and
then again as a fan and somebody wants
to improve even more like I wanna I want
to
help more chess players improve in
working with chessable to do that is is
massively exciting
um so those are some of the the top ones
uh there's many more there's many other
great things that play Magnus has uh
that's coming to to join in the
chess.com family
um but I'll focus on those for now
yeah I I get I gave you only only one so
that's good those who don't know Eric is
a fan he legitimately is a fan he's
watching every single show and giving
feedback in real time sometimes driving
us crazy can I say that it's true though
but Eric watches more chess content than
probably anybody in the world Andreas
thank you so much for being here man I
know this is this has meant so much to
you this year and and getting this
through uh you guys worked so hard and
built something super special over the
last few years uh with with chess 24 and
the play Magnus group in the tour so I'm
going to kind of ask you like a
different version of the question not
just what you're excited about but this
year what was the moment if anything or
what was the Tipping Point that for you
kind of cemented that you knew this was
the right home for for your family and
and for for your community that you guys
have built and coming together with
chess.com what was what was the one
thing if if there was one thing that
really felt right to you about about
getting this thing done
thanks annano it's actually really good
to be here I watched the status a few
times and you know it's a bit surreal to
actually be on the show in a good way
so uh you know when it comes to like
um if there was a time I don't know
um it was a very long process as you
said you know so I had a lot of a lot of
time to like think about if this was
like is this the right thing to do
I think what I want to say is that we
have to we look at many different
stakeholders you know so it's both is
this the right thing for for the
community for our fans that was like one
aspect the other one is for our
employees and then of course also we had
owners people that had believed in our
company
so I would say that you know as we got
to know each other
um what was the most important thing for
me was when I saw that you know our
missions were very aligned maybe we
articulated them a little bit
differently you know so like Eric talks
about you know growing the game we
talked about it in a slightly different
way but like I felt it meant the same
so you know so that was like that was
huge and you know as when I got to you
know meet you and I saw that our teams
met you how we kind of came together
and then it's like the cultural fit of
our of our people you know like the the
the teams that are you know the people
that are working for chess.com work for
play Magnus group they are generally
very very passionate about Chess and you
know what these people are allowed to
work together uh I think it's like much
better that that's being done in one
company than like a two seven companies
so like I it's not like it wasn't like
one moment but it was probably like more
gradually
um
but it was it was a great process thank
you yeah it makes sense a lot a lot of
little things adding up over overnight
at times it seems and Eric I'm gonna
throw to you we'll we'll keep working
through the different different points
um that uh that this means
Andreas was mentioning the mission
obviously growing the game today we'll
just share with the world you had a you
had an AMA just for our company right
talking you know our company's growing
we've got a lot of people involved now
and and two companies coming together
what are some of the things that that
are being talked about internally that
people are excited about and when you
talk about the mission in our culture
what would be your message kind of on
that topic just speaking internally
about about our our groups of people
working together before we even talk
about what it means for the fans
yeah I mean our missions you know we've
got I guess three missions in our
mission statement uh one is to serve the
community one is to grow the game and
the other third one is to be the best
possible place to work on the planet and
that is that's creating an environment
where people can work on a mission where
they feel enabled and empowered as like
a human and to work in a in a remote
environment within a very Global and
diverse company
um and to feel really empowered in their
role and to grow
um so bringing even more people together
with this we're now at at 600 plus
people
um and so you know to create that level
of environment for for that many people
is a challenge but also an amazing
opportunity and one I'm very much
looking forward to
um so you I would answer with that
primarily
you just said 600 plus people and I
almost blacked out a little bit that's
crazy um that that's even a thing for
for a little a little chess company
um but uh yeah that that's where we're
at Andreas the I guess we'll start to
transition to the fans here and all that
you kind of be the first to address as a
fan of Chess yourself what are you most
excited about right uh Eric mentioned
the tour and and Hikaru and Magnus on
Sunday what gets you super excited about
uh what we're going to be doing in the
in the coming years here
yeah no no I I want to follow up a
little bit on that actually because I
think what we should be very proud of
all of us is um you know we had we had
this uh this chess boom you know so a
lot of good things happen for Justin in
the last years and so many people came
and started to watch but that that was
not enough right it was so it was the
fact that you know play Magnus group on
our side we created you know the Magnus
Carlsen chess tour that became the
Champions Chester you know that I think
was you know very important innovation
on our side you did you you created
great events with poke Champs and others
so you know there was a market momentum
there but like we took it and and we did
something with it and that's the reason
why I think the growth continues you
know the growth of Chess didn't stop
after the pandemic it just continued to
go and that was because we all did
something together and um I think what
and Eric touched on it right so I think
the fact that our events are coming
together and it can be like one place is
where all the best players are competing
and I also think over like a whole
season I think that's something that is
quite important for a sport that like
you have something that goes on over a
long time I like that
uh so that's like one area which is very
exciting uh the other one is always
around learning and you know accessible
and our we have invested a lot into like
creating tools and content for people
that don't only want to play but that
really want to improve and learn chess
and we are very very excited about
seeing some of the creators and and you
know some of the of the content creators
on chess.com also have the opportunity
to come over to chessable and create
courses like I think that's another area
that that that's pretty huge
yeah well you're and you're teasing some
up ahead speaking of creators and some
big commitments of uh some of the
biggest the biggest streamers and names
in the world just you know we're going
to talk about that a little bit later on
um to make sure that we deliver on a
bunch of little announcements that feel
kind of big on a big day uh Eric I wanna
I wanna get to the uh the third bullet
point in our slide if we if we bring
that back up because now that Magnus
Carlson is an ambassador like have you
guys talked about your constant
impersonations of him and are we still
going to see that like what is in the
future for you
as Magnus Carlson
how can you ask me that I don't even
know if Magnus has seen that I don't
know what he thinks about it I expect to
get like a WhatsApp just watching right
A Moment Like never do that again I have
no idea
well I mean I I don't know I don't know
that he feels that way I think a lot of
people are are looking for faster hard
um as a future sponsor but all right um
okay Eric I'm gonna throw it back to you
Andreas mentioned go ahead
no I was gonna say I'm so excited to
have Magnus as an ambassador I mean he
he is I mean I you know
the the greatest test player we've ever
seen and so him to play on our platform
is is phenomenal I mean and again like
when we started chess.com we picked like
the humble Pawn as our logo because we
wanted to be chess for everyone it
wasn't you know the King logo because we
were for the Kings but you know it was
just chess for everyone but to see that
eventually over time that we now are the
platform still for everyone but
including the King of Chess like right
it's pretty awesome for me as a fan and
pretty humbling for me as you know the
person who one of the people started
this company
were you surprised to see that a a
Sunday match after the World Cup which
we had Carl and Magnus Drew what it did
or are you just like no checks the box
that's what everyone wants to see
I mean
was there a World Cup I don't remember
because yeah the blue line
yep it was our second most like viewed
show ever like it was phenomenal yeah
crazy well we're gonna get into all that
in a lot more events uh coming up and of
course some questions for Magnus on
whether whether he was surprised and how
how much he's already maybe looking
forward to Revenge I don't know how many
people were surprised by hikaru's
Victory sorry I can't go full fan mode
we gotta we gotta keep talking through
these points so um Andre for you of
course we are going to be getting
questions from our community reminder
chat if you're here watching
cue up some good questions and and make
them good ones make them tough ones the
uh the team who's working hard is going
to bring them to us we're going to start
getting to your questions in about five
minutes but
um Andreas going back to the to the
company stuff you know this is um
obviously it's a new world where where
we're all together and today we're going
to talk as much as we can about what we
know that that means but there's also
things we don't know that are coming but
you're you're um I guess anything else
you would you would want to say I guess
in terms of what this is meant to your
team specifically more than the
community to to kind of join join the
forces in some ways because there have
been ways where we've been kind of
competing a little bit right and that's
going away where we don't have to kind
of be punching at each other anymore
right let's just call it what it is what
are the things that you're excited about
from that perspective not you know I was
thinking with about this like I I
haven't worked in this um in this Chess
World as long as you I've worked there
for about now five years and also since
I joined the the play Magnus app and
Magnus I think it was back it was back
in 27 19 and you know I can hardly
recognize the landscape right I mean so
many things have happened in that short
time very very exciting things we have
been as I said before I think we've been
extremely lucky but it's not only enough
to be lucky you have to do something
with it and and we as people working in
this you know in this industry we have
done we've done a really good job over
the last years
I was thinking also about like the
number of people when I heard when I
heard the 600 number I think if you go
back to like 2017 how many people were
then working like play Magnus and
chesses come together I would say it's
probably like less than 100 people you
know something like that right
so what I what I'm really excited about
is basically this huge community of now
you know millions and millions of people
being active on our platforms
all the creators all the people doing
stuff you know on the streaming
platforms on the content creation side
combined with the 600 people that is
working our company
that's going to create some I think like
amazing products I don't know what they
are I don't think probably nobody knows
what they are but like it's going to
come some really really cool stuff out
of that
and there's a lot of energy here so that
that that's probably what makes me most
excited
yeah yeah I love it I love it well okay
we're going to talk about what it means
for the community I'm watching you chat
I know the community is bringing us
questions so let's get some specifics
right on the agenda let's bring up some
of the specific points we know it's
going to mean stronger content probably
some more focused content to the
different types of groups that we know
are out there in terms of Chess
enthusiasts consolidation of our events
the best players Under One Roof but in
reverse order Eric I want to start with
you there's something I have circled
there
um the third one down the the improved
insights with aim chess one of the one
of the companies Within the play Magnus
group family that maybe didn't know
about aim chess
um has uh has a lot of expertise in this
area we've been building a lot of things
from an insights perspective so Eric why
don't you talk a little bit about that
you can choose another one from our
product menu but I think a lot of people
are interested right it's Advanced
analytics for chess how do I get better
not just instant feedback about a game
but about all of my games and where I
can improve as a player so take it away
from a product chess fan perspective
what gets you excited about that
yeah I mean aim chest has built some
really amazing technology and they do
have you know users and subscribers
there who play on chess.com and play
other places and upload their games and
get some insights
um you know and people who want to
continue using aim chest will be able to
do that and that can be their home but
also uh we hope to bring that technology
to uh chess.com as well where you know I
don't know 10 million games plus are
played per day and if we can feed that
in
um you know for those of you who haven't
checked out your insights uh it gives
you some really interesting things there
but there's more that can be said and
over time that's an area we want where
we want to invest because the more you
can learn in some ways passively from
the games you're playing and pick up
someone says oh that's something that I
do or that's something I can learn from
or oh that points to a weakness in my
game or that's that you know or there's
a course that that meets my needs and
will help me improve in this opening or
thing so there's a lot of pieces of this
ecosystem that will come together around
learning and playing and learning and
improving that come at the end of The
Funnel of playing so you play games
right and then what do you do after that
what do you what what are your takeaways
and then what can you work on and so we
this acquisition in many ways helps us
you know flesh out that funnel better uh
but you know more games are played on
test.com than anywhere else by far and
so it makes sense for us that that
continues on in this journey and aim
chest is a big part of that
yeah when we talk about recommending
courses when are we deleting the hard
line of code that says never mention an
Anish giri course like is that required
as part of this or
who's in charge of that being that
code's being pushed live right now a
niche we are
as somebody who has spent time with
Anisha obviously we like to tease each
other a little bit uh no we're so
excited like there's so many great
creators as you said uh and I don't want
to spill spill your your tea too early
but you know there's a lot of great
creators a lot of Great Courses coming
um and we're just excited that the
community can come together around
content and there's you know no more
kind of awkwardness in those things
although things with the niche and me
will probably always be awkward just
because of our personalities and anyway
you know what I'm saying yeah yep there
they will remain awkward and believe me
they are going to get more Awkward on
this show as we go um don't worry about
that Anish if you're watching it has
only just begun all right um I had some
more specific questions I want to get
into my product but I'm being told we
got a lot of great feature chat
questions lined up so let's let's do it
let's start diving in so we're gonna
we're gonna bring up our feature chat
questions first and foremost uh from
from the team we've got let's see well
well I'm gonna I'm gonna let it be fed
but we've got
um questions about what you're most
excited about I think we kind of got to
that I want to ask about the
commentators the commentators okay what
are we most excited about I do think we
talked a lot about that
um I uh I think I think you know the
Champions Tour the players Under One
Roof and and the product there it's a
good question from the community we'll
we'll kind of get into more specific
ones as we go I want to get to the
second one that asks about the the
commentators coming to chess.com and um
you know I guess I can actually answer
that and say that you know our plan is
is everybody's going to be working
together right so rather than thinking
about it it's just 24 coming to
chess.com you might see some chess.com
commentators you know headed to Oslo in
the studio and again I don't want to
reveal too much about how we're going to
operate with the uh kind of the new
combined series of events for the tour
but um but you're gonna see everybody
working together who do you want in fact
I'm going to ask you community list and
chat do you want Robert Hessler working
with David Howell or do you want you
know Dania Dania working with Ivanka
houska and and everywhere in between
right again as long as Anish Gary's not
involved I'm open to any commentary
pairings that the community can come up
with so all right
um here's a good one Eric I'm gonna
throw it to you I'm gonna throw to you
so will accounts and paid features on
all Sites chess chess.com chess 24 be
combined what is the what is the early
plan if you're a subscriber out there
who who's who's dabbling in all of it
what are the ways we're going to kind of
navigate that and bring value to
everybody
yeah
the honest answer is we don't totally
know yet and there's no like immediate
levers that we're pulling there's like
no easy magic strings and dots that you
kind of like touch together and then it
all works it's just that's not how code
is
um and there's still discussions to be
had about how these some of these
ecosystems and products work together
um so that said we want to deliver the
most we can to fans we understand that
you're paying and subscribing at
sometimes in different places and we
want to make that easy for you so we
actually would love feedback from the
community of how you envision this kind
of working together
um and so we've got some ideas and we're
starting on that process but you know we
haven't been able to operate as the same
company even though we've had this
acquisition being discussed for a long
time we've been acting as separate
companies and so now that this is kind
of coming together there's more
discussions happening how do we serve
fans which tools make sense where you
know different things chessable has a
classroom chess.com has a classroom like
are we gonna have two classrooms one
classroom where does it live you know
what about features if you're following
events on chest 24 you also can follow
chess on on chess.com events so how does
that all work together there's a lot
there's a lot of questions around this
we don't have all the answers yet but we
are putting on the lenses of we're chess
fans we're chess users ourselves where
does this make the most sense how do we
piece this all together and all of your
feedback is very helpful with that
yeah it's true and you know we are going
to be getting to this in a later section
uh we have the head of chessable and a
VP of content joining so I'll just say
there are going to be some special
opportunities some some discounts and
some stuff that celebrate this without
getting too specific about it but I want
to get into the next question this comes
from velvet canyon19 who kind of asked a
similar one which is what's going to
happen to the user base of Premium
memberships on the PMG apps I mean
high level you're not going to lose
anything right so if you're a premium
user over there everything is going to
stay there's not there's not a
disappearance of your your premium
membership so if you're watching this
and you're like hey I'm subscribing to
the play Magnus app and you know aim
chess and this and that like that's
going to continue right so you're not
you're not seeing any of that disappear
you know and I think over time as we
look at the right ways to add value
there may be more out value added both
ways you know from tech and and user
stuff to the to the PMG apps and and the
products there as well as integrating
Tech and maybe adding value to the
diamond membership or whatever else you
have so sorry Eric I stole that one
um that's great the uh sorry A lot of
these are going to be are going to be
going um back to you guys I mean unless
both you guys how you're going to answer
this one a a a chance to swing and Miss
will our will this company ever go
public Andreas has some experience with
that this is a good chance to punt but
I'll let you guys answer that question
however should we go public you tell me
what do you think about running about
everybody I can tell you that I used I'm
not sure if I had a lot of hair even
before we went public but it's
definitely uh more great than what it
used to be so you know it's uh it's not
an easy process but maybe it's also an
opportunity for you know for more people
to participate also as owners and also
like there are some poses and minuses
there I I think it's something that that
like is important to to continuously
discuss
yeah I appreciate it I understand that
and and I agree I only want to say just
that a lot of people do ask and say can
I invest in chess.com I get that
question pretty frequently and if you're
and the answer is no because when you're
private it's really challenging to do
that but I also agree with Andreas like
there's people who in the community who
want to invest in the community and I
think it'd be great for chess to be in
in the hands of you know of the public
and people who can help steer that and
invest in its future
no but just like a short thing there
right because uh if you if you looked at
play Magnus which was obviously
um a much smaller company on a
standalone basis we had so many
shareholders you know it was so many
people from around mainly in Europe that
you know wanted to own a piece of of
these companies because I think many of
them were passionate about the game yeah
yeah which is a good sign if there were
uh even more even more people who wanted
to have a piece of it we don't know the
plans as they kind of said but who knows
we all right I want to I want to see how
we answer this one there's a question
about uh things for the public not going
public but are there plans for live
coaching and master classes through
either of the chess.com or accessible
classroom products and Eric
um
I'm gonna let you kind of uh answer that
one however you want live coaching
master classes classroom chessable what
do you got there
I feel I feel like this is your way of
like needling me along of what you
personally want to see I know so I get
it and like you're doing it in front of
a lot of people and you're making you
make this came from user Zone Zone horse
one so I didn't make it up yeah you're
Zone horse one I know you are
um anyway uh the answer is that's
definitely something we've been thinking
of uh at chess.com and I've still just
been trying to figure out the right way
to do that you know Andreas and I
haven't synced on this I know that
they've tried this
um and seen you know some learnings
there frankly it's not a discussion
we've had and it's one we need to have I
don't know Andreas you want to share
publicly in front of me I think like I
mean yeah chessable you know which has
which is of course a little bit more
should we say a very it's a very engaged
Learning Community around the orders and
you know as part of like when we have
released some of the adjustable courses
there's also been like some master
classes with the with the authors like
combined with it and I know that that's
you know that has been extremely
appreciated by in all the um by the
Learning words but also by the authors
so it has been a great way for them to
to connect so I think that's something
we can discuss with Garrett when he
comes on on the show later later today
because it's definitely I think it's
it's it's it's a great it's a great
great question actually yeah
and just to Insight to the tension that
everyone just felt there between me and
Eric we've been having discussions about
this for probably a decade I mean I
don't know it's been a long time and we
won't give a shout out to the other
co-founder Jay who's not here who also
believes in this feature look we believe
in this big time Andreas and and Garrett
and the chessable team believe in this
big time and I think that you know we've
invested so much in coaching
um and Coach the AI but we definitely
believe that there's a there's a home
for this and there's just a lot to
unpack there as far as actually bringing
it to life so all right I'm going to
jump to the last question here by the
way there were so many I'm gonna I'm
gonna jump to um we this came into from
knee of Atari ni of tari wants to know
whether Magnus will be streaming more or
when is he gonna start streaming more as
if it's a foregone conclusion I'm gonna
take that one and say that might be a
question you should save for Magnus when
Magnus is here and I will I will be
happy and willing to put him on the spot
about that because he and I have had um
he and I have had a lot of discussions
about that and it might be interesting
to see how Magnus feels about it people
know he have he has done that from time
to time and I'm going to answer one that
came earlier about there being banter
blitzes remember we're not we're not
going to take anything away that feels
bad but one of the cool things that
chess.com has done that's just 24 you
know hasn't invested in much yet because
they were doing good stuff elsewhere is
the streamer's kind of ecosystem right
in a lot of ways we feel that the banter
Blitz merger with helping even more of
the chess 24 kind of faces to the
community build their own streaming
Brands is a big part of what um we're
excited to be able to help them do as
well so it's kind of a yes and it's not
a no but things are going away it's kind
of a yes and things might evolve into
into spaces that are even better for
everyone who who loves those things so
um I I stole one in there I stole one
and answered the banter Blitz one too so
all right keep that question for Magnus
Eric and Andreas I can't keep you here
because we got a lot more to do um and
you guys got a couple of uh companies to
run that are now one company so we're
gonna we're gonna let you get to that
um
thank you thank you for being here guys
and we really appreciate you and can't
believe we got here
bye-bye
all right
well
um that was awesome and the the
conversation could probably just keep
going and get more and more just kind of
behind the scenes we we wouldn't mind
that but there's a lot more to get to
and a lot of the questions you're
bringing chat are probably going to be
answered by other guests and other
topics that we have coming up for those
of you just tuning in we have a big run
of show it is the end of year the
quarter four December Edition for the
state of chess.com plenty more ahead
when we come back we're going to be
diving in to some of the big questions
about events we're going to be talking
about what the calendar and the mergers
of the champions tour and the global
Championship mean so don't go anywhere
when we come back we're joined by two
more special guests and diving in to a
lot more that you want to know about and
we will be back in just a few
foreign
[Music]
loving the world's Premier online speed
chess tournament well you're probably
gonna love just.com's coverage of the
premiere over-the-board speed chess
tournament updates that turn
a ship commences December 26th in
Kazakhstan and features hundreds of the
world's best players competing in an
exciting free-for-all format
defending Champions seek to extend their
reign
Legends strive to reclaim this
prestigious title
an aspiring talents hope to break
through and win their first world
championship title
who will win it all tune into
chess.com's live coverage to find out
just played an exciting game and want to
see if you got a brilliancy or maybe
where you could have improved
chess.com's game review is just a click
away game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play
with retry mistakes you can get another
shot at finding missed opportunities
try game review today on web iOS or
Android
what is this this is duck chess you guys
this is a new variant it's called duck
chess chest but with a duck quack quack
how to play duck chest the duck is a
brick pieces cannot move through the
square occupied by the duck click on a
square to place the dog
[Music]
oh he put the deck to prevent moves of
opponent not yourself
yeah so basically you do this and this
cannot move I'm gonna go Knight F6 and
I'm gonna put the duck in the most
inconvenient place for my opponent to
move no Bishop no Queen so no londons
can permanently stop the London capture
the pawns Keen to win oh wow though
there's no stalemate but still wait
there is still meat but the still mated
player wins ooh if only that was real
chess I think I'm getting the hang of
this game I think I think I actually am
getting the hang of it
I think this works oh that's a horrible
blunder oh my God I just blundered I
have to move something else first then
dark and Knight will take my king this
is the best way to lose the dog chest
[Music]
there are some real bullet skills right
there boys this is the fast time winning
duck chest that That's so exciting
oh no no no no no no slip no no no no no
no I won
ah duck chess champion give me those
points baby
[Music]
all right
chess kit is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
to kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest bustles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids
chess kit is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
[Music]
my name is Ethan Curry
welcome back everyone the state of
chess.com continues here always feels
good to get to get that first segment
out of the way the nerves are gone the
community is chirping we see you chat
and so much more to continue to dive
into today we teased before the break
that we were going to dive into one of
the biggest topics people have not just
because it's the events that they all
want to watch with the best players in
the world but it means a lot for where
you're going to watch and the channels
and and how we're going to break down a
very busy calendar year I'm going to
quickly set the high level right now of
what the 2023 kind of events menu looks
like before bringing on a couple guys
who are even more qualified than me to
talk about it the chess.com events
calendar is going to start in quarter
one with something we're kind of calling
team chess season the Collegiate chess
league is back along with the pro chess
League those two things are going to be
bigger and better than they ever have
been if you haven't seen the growth in
our College Programs you might be
surprised within the next couple years
just how many kids on campuses around
the world are playing chess and what the
CCL means to them so so stay tuned for
that the PCO you know what it is I
already know that many of the best
players in the world have signed with
teams and we're going to talk about that
the streamer community events we've run
they're going to continue with a busy
calendar sometimes people might be
worried is anything going to sacrifice
the answer is no Magnus playing in title
Tuesdays we have Arena Kings going
puzzle week we'll start the first week
of January for those who are super into
our Puzzle Battle tool or solving with
puzzle Rush that's going to be coming
too but in the middle of the year we
will move into our speed chess kind of
season it's all the events you know it's
jscc it's Junior SCC it's the main SEC
but of course the bullet Chess
Championship and the I'm not a GM SEC
will also be around there too it's the
fastest events we do much earlier right
we just wrapped up with the SEC now here
comes the SEC in quarter two but
the next thing I want to talk about is a
lot of people have been asking what has
happened to our our celebrity kind of
Pro-Am events right the last one we did
was Blitz Champs in the summer but
there's a lot more coming with that it's
been kind of an interesting up and down
ride for all of our POG Champs uh fans
so many probably watching this maybe got
into chess from POG Champs there is a
lot more coming that I wasn't even
allowed to put on this board because
there's too many moving Parts we're
doing a huge event with rolling stone
that we are now teasing for the first
time it's going to be sexy and loud and
awesome and in New York and I can't say
anything more about it probably said too
much more events with NFL NBA NHL so
many athletes interested in doing some
fun stuff and then we will have a Pog
Champs return
um I'm not going to dive more into that
but it's all going to be happening next
year so okay that kind of lets you know
that the investment is going to remain
and the fans are going to get what they
want with all the different styles of
events but probably the biggest question
about this merger and I've been watching
chat this whole time besides the fun
troll questions and the questions about
what Eric's wearing does he ever put on
anything but a t-shirt no one knows I
think Eric only has t-shirts sorry
that's his wardrobe but uh they want to
know what's going to happen with the
Champions chess tour
the Magnus Carlsen tour originally
evolved Champions chess tour then the
chess.com Global Championship where are
we headed with that so to help me break
that down I'm now going to bring on two
guys who are uh who are more than in the
Weeds on this topic they are The
Visionaries along with many other
stakeholders but these two guys
chess.com's VP of Esports Michael
brancato joins us and the tour director
for the chess 24 Champions Tour RNE
Jorge he is with us joining I believe
from Norway um RNA and um I'm gonna
start
I'm going to start with you man again uh
the big topic first welcome to state of
Chess you are together with chess.com
I've known you for many years man I know
your excitement your passion your
mission when it comes to Growing the
game and making it more accessible to to
larger audience audiences so what gets
you most excited about what we're
bringing together into this new series
and what are you pumped to do now that
chess.com and the Champions chess tour
are one
oh where to start uh it's just so
amazing to to be a part of this uh
incredible Evolution I would say within
the within the Chess World that we bring
really bright Minds together that has
been modeling uh on our different sites
and now finally can be able to we can
take what we have been doing for a
broadcasting chess on a level never been
done before uh for a wider audience take
that into reach an incredible membership
base that js.com has and and together
really create some amazing events and
with that incredible reach for millions
of millions of ads
for those who didn't know RNA horvai is
is the guy who's been behind it I see so
many fans in chat who are talking about
the tour and what they love about it
aren't they so that's awesome and this
is this is one of the guys I don't want
to give you all the credit for the team
watching but you are one of the
Visionaries and so it's super awesome to
have you Michael you've had a vision to
to make chess tournament formats more
like Smash tournament formats since you
got here just kidding but that is one of
the things you do
um what are you most excited about in
regards to the specifics besides just
getting all the best players in in one
event we know we didn't have Magnus
playing in the global championship last
year we now do uh what what are you most
excited about just quick high level
before we get in the details
yeah so again there's so many things but
uh I guess one I want to call out as the
guy who had the deal with the brunt of
this of last year is having schedules
that are actually in sync
um up until this point you know between
you know the Champions chess tour the
global Championship the rapid chess
championships and all the over-the-board
events out there like schedules are all
over the place they're always stepping
on each other
and now that we're collaborating we can
finally coordinate on like a schedule
that is cohesive and makes sense and
it's best for everyone involves that's
that's for me that's That's so exciting
no no more fans choosing on a weekend or
or toggling between Magnus and uh the
whoever was competing in that major of
the champions tour and the RCC and all
those things so I'm with you on that as
a as a fan who did too much of that I
can't wait for it all right we got a lot
of questions guys we're gonna have you
here for the next 15-20 minutes in chat
remember we're going to get specific
questions to them but let's bring up
let's bring up the uh the details of
what what we are sharing at this point
the cgc that's the chess.com Global
championship and the CCT in 2023 are
gonna be one this is the best of both
worlds and uh we will we will be talking
about what what the uh what the
nomenclature is of that how the events
are called the really well there's a lot
of work into that but let's just say
what matters is it's going to be one and
it's going to have the best players in
the world in one circuit as you can see
it's gonna have a total prize fund of
more than two million dollars for that
single event it's a lot of money for
that for that tour and there of course
will be more prizes in the SEC and the
PCL combined but we're pretty excited to
be to be in a two million dollar cash
prize to just that event and then we're
going to have all kinds of the formats
that the players told us they really
love Armageddon the bidding formats the
rapid time controls so RNA uh getting
all the players in one circuit what does
that mean to you as a guy who's been
helping lead the vision last year we
were we were splitting up the players
right you didn't have everybody
competing in the events you wanted and
and chess.com felt the same way what do
you feel like the product really
represents to fans when you know that
all the best in the world are competing
for this and there's no debate about
who's there and what are you able to
bring to life in those moments
that's going to be so exciting both to
execute it just as much for the viewers
to actually know that they're going to
see the best players find it out or and
really create some amazing moments of
the boards and knowing that we're gonna
have Magnus and Hikaru fighting in in
the same uh year-long season uh as some
of the top names and this that's going
to be that's going to be really really
we keep mentioning Magnus and Hikaru
because all the all the fans do that but
I want to say again I mean there's
everybody too I mean and there's a
there's a cash prize choice that had to
be made in the past and now there's just
you know kind of one Natural Choice and
and we'll know that all the best players
will be competing for it I I want to
bring up more specifics on the tour
because the road to what we're calling
the championship at the end of this
event right right now uh is is gonna be
one that I really think combines The
Best of Both Worlds Michael but I'm
going to let you kind of go through what
you feel is most important on the format
as a guy who's probably been been more
more focused there than anyone else
right is it is it the open qualifiers
you love that anyone can compete is it
obviously the price is just for those
events are pretty significant but
getting everybody into the final
championship in December what can you
reveal about how that format is going to
break down that you think is going to be
super interesting for fans
yeah sure so for me the most exciting
part is the whole Open qualifier system
um I think that if there's if there's
one like big critique I had of the
Champions chess tour of of the past is
that all all the players were kind of
invited to each event and there wasn't
really a chance for
um I guess some of them were under the
radar players to to get a chance to like
prove their skills and find a way in and
um based on titles that players got into
the path through fide and also our own
leaderboards um anyone's gonna have an
opportunity to I guess I'll throw their
hat in the ring and be able to make
their way into each of the six events
um and I think it's going to open up a
lot more opportunity for players and
also create a more varied Fields um in
these events
um so okay I'm gonna start there yeah oh
go ahead
no no you continue okay yeah you've got
nothing to say you do you yeah
yeah I'm also I'm really excited to
bring more double elimination to chess
um you you kind of hint that it's like
I'm bringing smash formats it's not just
a smash format but it's one that is very
popular in gaming and uh I'm not gonna
lie I'm not the biggest fan of round
robin which um is typically what chess
events use um I think that why is that
mistake so double click on that defend
yourself to the chess Community why
why double elimination
um
oh round Robins
a bunch of reasons I mean one of them is
that there is no clear like defining
moment at the end like there's no clear
like this is the finals or this is the
match the term and like who wins the
tournament it's kind of like they play a
bunch of games at the end of it there's
a winner and sometimes that Winners
decided before even the last round is
played and then you also have things
like sometimes players are yeah that
happens all the time uh in fact I ended
up happening in in the finals of the
2022 uh CCT
um yeah but there's also you know if
players get off to a rough start then
they're kind of they're playing games
that don't have any real implication
um for them because you know they're
ready out of the running and then they
might inadvertently affect you know
other players chances
um and yes there's a lot of things like
that that I I think round robin has its
place
um and brown Robin is actually going to
be a part of the playoffs format that we
have here but it won't be like the the
main go-to format that we use um and
with double elimination I think this
extra exceptionally queer with every
match you get losers brackets storylines
and then runs there and get you know who
who can make a you know a Deep Run and
and you know reset the bracket and Grand
finals
um players still get more than one
chance so compared to a single
elimination you know if you are unlucky
and get seated for a Spanish Carlson
around one voice without a chance in the
losers bracket um to prove yourself I
just think it's kind of like I I guess
the op the optimal format on it honestly
um and I I'm just a really big fan of it
look up it's interesting I you know
Arnie it makes me want to um throw over
to you knowing knowing you for as long
as I have
um and and that you know you've had such
a great vision on bringing chess to
larger audiences and we've seen what
happened with Norway since Magnus
Carlson but it it wasn't just Magnus
right there were so many so many people
behind helping to bring chess on these
major TV networks as Michael talks about
the formats that are best for
competition what do you think about the
format is going to be best for for
audiences especially those who maybe
don't know all the details of of how
some of these Esports competitions or
double elim and all that stuff works
like what to you is the most important
thing about how this this championship
series is presented to broader fans and
what do you think they care about most
I think that they uh what they care
about is the excitement and uh the the
mental battles happening uh between the
brightest Minds in the world uh so even
though we don't necessarily understand
everything that's happening over the
board itself but you get so mesmerized
but incredible talent that these guys
have in their heads uh these and and
being able to communicate that in a way
that's understandable for a wide
audience even though you haven't studied
a lot of Chess Theory from before that
is that is really crucial for to making
the game which has grow to a wider
audience and doing like we're going to
do now for the coming season with having
double elimination having every single
day counts it's it's a there's going to
be decisive moments every single day of
uh of the event then the storytelling is
gonna be even better to go out there for
the audience as well to understand that
uh okay either do or die every single
day of the event and yes you get if you
die you get a second chance but then if
you die again you are completely out of
it and I think that
um that's uh that's a really cool way to
take this further because what we are
doing here is we are pushing the
envelope uh keeping the respect of the
sport but at the same time also making
it even more accessible interesting and
up to date for a wider audience
it makes sense Michael going back to the
slide we we talked about the open
qualifiers we've talked in the Weeds
about some things we want to do with the
format we see that we are going to be
again bringing a 200 000 first place
prize that was the richest prize for any
first place Victor of any tournament
last year and we'll be we'll be matching
that again but what can you say about
the finals RNA talked about it being
super exciting the fact that every day
someone's life is is kind of at stake
what can you tell us about the format of
the finals as a compares to what the cgc
was versus Champions chest tour and and
I know we're going to be breaking down
this but just give a give a little
teaser to the to the fans kind of wet
the appetite
yeah sure so there's elements of both
events which I think kind of represents
kind of this Union of of the of the two
previous event series like the Champions
chess tour ended at the round robin and
this the CTC ended on a knockout bracket
um and I'm not gonna go like two in the
weeds here but um we're basically having
a round robin playoff phase
um that ultimately feeds players into a
four-player uh single elimination uh
bracket at the end of it so you kind of
get the element of all the best players
are playing each other
um but then also at the end there's like
very clear Stakes uh you know there's
the semi-finalists and then there's you
know the kind of we go down to the final
match um with everything on the line
so you are doing some round robin stuff
right but but we are we are but but
there's there's a Twist to it I don't
want to spoil the twist yet but I was
gonna say it's not just straight like
round robin in the top four there's
there's going to be a little more to it
there
um but I don't want to spoil that on
this show
okay all right well guys this is um this
is awesome I actually was going to tee
up a few questions that I just um got
kind of notified by our team who's
crushing it thank you and our community
bringing us good questions that it's we
we got some of them that uh the
community naturally is is throwing at us
that are similar uh to the ones we would
continue to discuss so I'm going to
start at the top with 515 rock climber
uh who ask a question that we're not
going to totally get into right now but
I'm gonna acknowledge it because it is
important wants to know when the cgc and
the CCT combined what will the name be
we have been talking a lot about this
and it really matters not just from a
branding perspective and and how we want
to work with partners and and sponsors
to to continue to grow the game and and
hopefully by by bringing in more uh
commercialized sponsorship we're
improving prize funds and the
livelihoods of the players so it's a it
is a big deal right and we've been
really thinking through how to do that
uh but to not put my foot in my mouth as
I normally do we're not going to do that
right now because a lot of those
discussions are ongoing but I promise it
will be clear it'll make sense
um and uh it will also be the kind of
thing that allows us to continue to work
with Partners in an effective way to uh
to give them the the love that they want
for their support so all right
this is an interesting one
um Chiron Hogg wants to know how will
the merger affect player ratings I'm
going to twist that into a question for
you Michael and say that
what is the qualification process like
is it only for title players is it open
to just the highest rated players you
say it's open just how open is it and
will ratings play a part in that
yeah so radians indirectly play A Part
um so titled players are always eligible
to play in our events
um but I think the one new thing we're
doing is we're actually going to be
using the chess.com leaderboards the
determine eligibility
uh so
um it's for the event it's going to be
if your top 500 uh then you are able to
play in the event and so that isn't
based on just your rating although your
rating is probably pretty closely tied
to your to your ranking but that's going
to be based on the ranking so if you
want a chance to play in the event you
got to go up on our leaderboard and get
higher
okay so not just title players but
leaderboards so ratings really matter
then makes sense I mean
the all right guys there's there's a ton
of questions left but there's also a a
world champion uh waiting in the wings
who wants to join our show
um again I apologize to the community
maybe I should have jumped into those
earlier we will save some of the best
ones uh for the end of the AMA for sure
but I want to give one more question I
guess uh to to RNA because some people
asking uh what will the frequency of
these online tournaments be that's from
Japan night 19 and I'm going to turn
that into what will be the frequency of
the of the the Oslo studio right the uh
the the traditional kind of production
team you had I kind of know the answer
to this one but I think a lot of people
want to know that the high level
production stuff you guys are doing is
going to stay even if we're mixing in
talent and some of the graphics and
things as we're merging a new brand how
involved is the studio going to be
what's the frequency of the studio uh
going to be for the new championship
we are going to see uh the studio cover
every single major in the tournament uh
and also uh the Challenger on the finals
happening as well so there's going to be
a broadcast with uh with um with Oslo
studio and uh Talent you are well
acquainted with and uh mixing up Talent
as you're saying as well uh daddy that's
gonna happen for each and every of the
tournaments uh which
um means about every single every second
month
what's the one Talent pairing you want
to avoid RNA be honest who do you not
want working together just for what
might happen
well I don't want to work uh have
working together
uh well I tend to hold mean that most
people are able to work together uh so I
took all the spot there but I really
don't have a good good answer on that
what I want to what I want the chat to
help me and make sure happens is that I
want to see you in our outsole studio as
soon as possible Danny
well I'm I'm excited about it I was kind
of teasing you because the trick
question that was a trick question the
answer is always as long as the niche
giri is not working with anybody that
we're happy so anyway you you failed
that one but we'll we'll uh we'll we'll
keep we'll keep bringing you some some
stuff I'll I'll get it next time I
apologize anyway RNA seriously man I
just want to say personally it's a
pleasure you and I have known each other
we're together uh these two guys worked
together the first ever official random
World Championship lots of History we
could talk about but this is super
exciting uh Michael as well thanks for
joining man can't wait to see this come
to life I'm gonna let you both go so we
can we can get set for the for the next
segment in the very special guest but
appreciate it and we can't wait for the
new the new events coming next year
thanks for having me all right
that was Michael brancato VP of East
first and RNA horvai who is the tour
director they're working super hard and
a lot of these things are in progress
this deal only closed a few days ago of
Team uh I say team is in our family
watching so we're not just like avoiding
things some of this stuff is like we
were just so excited to throw it out
there but it is a work in progress and
they are working harder than anybody to
do it all right I am I am going to take
a very quick break before working hard
with all of you to make sure that the
world chess champion gets all the
questions we want to give him and uh and
really uh really we can dive into his
brain in our next segment so that's
right don't go anywhere when we come
back we will be joined by none other
than World chess champion Magnus Carlson
right here on the state of just.com
foreign
[Music]
Chicago is asking where I'm born and
raised so that's how I got the name I
guess they call me the muscle I'm the
one with the passion I'm always looking
for a good fight you know evidently they
don't make a difference man just
Checkmate coming up it don't matter
what we're trying to do is to let them
know hey we're playing down here in
Houston Texas
if you come down here help step in trust
me we're going to beat you you better
bring your game
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
I don't think I've ever seen a
performance like that ever he is the
winner of the FDX crypto cup he's gonna
win the tournament
Master Class
he's the best player in the world he's a
world champion
I'm excited to be uh I'm excited to be
part of the department
he is the best player in the world he's
the world champion I think Hikaru said
it best he is Magnus Carlson and he
joins us on the state of chess.com
Magnus thanks for being here man
thank you I uh I want to dive in to a
question that I know you answered in
August when we threw together that sort
of quick quick video to announce this
thing for those people who don't know
there's been a lot to this right and and
a lot of work to make this happen but
for you again what made you know for a
company that bears your likeness a
company that you built and helped found
that this was the right thing to do for
chess for the opportunity for you
yourself if you could just speak broadly
hand you the mic what what makes you
excited about this and what made you
feel like this was the right thing to do
I think it's going to be great for both
fans and and players a sim a simple a
stat that uh now that it will be easier
for all the best players to
uh to sort of compete in the same event
and it will be easier for the the fans
to to follow and that's uh really an
exciting prospect for for me as well to
be constantly competing with the with
the best in World online and probably
even more frequently than than I used to
yep for you is it is it does it feel
mostly about about the the the tour and
and bringing all the players together
the the other things that you've been
invested in like your app for example my
my son wanted to say he can't wait to
he's played your five-year-old Magnus
Carlson and wants to play it with the
other Bots are there anything else you
would say kind of broadly that you that
you know gets you pumped about about
this or for you is it mainly about about
the tour and all the players Under One
Roof
uh for me as a chess player uh it that's
certainly a big motivation but uh I'm of
course a shareholders as well in in the
play minus group and and for that it's
also exciting all the all the new
possibilities that we have both with um
with our apps and and testable
um
the the new possibilities for for
integration there so it's going to be
it's going to be fun to see and
hopefully uh generally just
it's great for for the um for the chess
fans and um
yeah yeah
makes sense I I want to stay on the
topic then as a player we're gonna make
this little casual kind of podcast style
I think for a lot of people the
questions they have are what do you feel
is next for you as a player what is left
for you to accomplish at this point in
your career right this was a big year
you declined the the opportunity to
defend the traditional the classical
World Chess Championship you're super
excited about the evolving formats of
online chess but how what are your
Ambitions left in your over-the-board
chess career 2900 rating and how do you
approach that and what are your thoughts
about what remains for you to to kind of
accomplish over the over the years to
come
well I don't have a lot of Ambitions for
for what to to accomplish but I love the
game I love playing so that's that's all
the ambition that I that I really need
and uh that's why I'm gonna continue to
to compete in the events that I um that
I enjoy
yep okay makes sense hey then moving on
um from the the over the board uh
Ambitions because you're right you don't
have a lot of Ambitions needed needed
there uh make sense but talking about
the evolution then the game broadly
right 200 000 plus people tuned in to
you and Hikaru on Sunday and the fans
clearly love you throwing down in fast
time controls not just against Hikaru
but others you you know you're
documented as kind of wanting wanting
there to be an evolution and to embrace
faster time patrols because you feel
like it's the more sporting element
um in some of your you know kind of uh
closed-door discussions with fide but
talk about that a little bit if you
would about what you feel is important
for the game as it's evolving you with
these online events that lead to these
live kind of finals and what what do you
think is important to see in these in
these modern chess formats to make sure
that the content Remains the most
exciting for fans
I I think your summarized it pretty
pretty well there uh I would also like
to mention uh Fisher random chess uh
which I would love to see more of in a
uh classical or at least slower time
control when it comes to regular uh
chess I feel that
[Music]
um
I fill out uh classical probably will be
sort of phased out a little bit at least
at the at the top level
um at least that's what I think sort of
should should happen
um I think
that um
the possibilities for discovering new
ideas in the opening especially are are
somewhat limited and
um you can see that in faster time
controls there's still more than enough
scope to to play and the game works in
in a great way obviously this is at the
top level at other levels it doesn't
doesn't matter as much
um but but yeah faster time controls it
matters a lot less there
um
it's probably better to have it that way
because people have the familiarity with
the with the the positions people can
see their own theory that
um they play without the games becoming
too too boring so so
um yeah I think uh
um that's one of the big reasons why
um
why faster chess is the is the way to to
go also a lot of the
uh audience or most of the audience is
online anyway so I think there's no
reason why we shouldn't play the games
mostly online as well
yeah it makes sense that I want to
double click on that because there's
there's still a lot of comparisons as
there should be right online chess is
different than over the board I mean
physically it feels different like the
energy of your opponent right is
different but but online chess is where
by far more more and more players are
playing in millions of games do you what
do you feel is the difference in your
approach and maybe even quality of play
like do you do you feel a difference
online versus over the board or do you
feel like in five years if you were
looking at Crystal Ball that'll be a
thing of the past that the the modern
generation is is playing just as high
quality online as they are over the
board or what are your thoughts on just
the comparisons there between online and
OTB
I feel like I play in speeches I play a
little bit better online probably uh
probably because
I'm more used to to that but it's too as
you said yeah it's two slightly
different ways of of seeing the
the bar but overall I'm not sure it
really
uh in the long run it will matter too
much in in terms of the um
of the quality I also really like the
hybrid events where you play online but
in person in more of a
Esports setting
um I think uh a lot can be be done there
in the in the future to make that very
very exciting as well
on that note were you were you surprised
by the record viewership that was it was
the most watched chest show second only
to game six of the uh 2021 World Chess
Championship that you may have may or
may not remember uh have been you were a
part of that so this show on Sunday with
Hikaru was the second most watched
single chess show we've we've ever had
and do you feel like the SCC style in
format is perfectly designed for what
you said that you really like those
hybrid events with playing on a computer
but in person with an opponent for fans
maybe in a live audience
yeah I think that's uh that's a great
idea
um and uh
I'd definitely to want to be a part of
of something like that
okay yeah were you surprised by the
viewership or you're like no I expect
throwing down with Hikaru I expected
that
I expected it to be popular
um yeah the exact numbers I don't should
have an have an opinion on uh except
that
um yeah if it's comparable with the with
the classical World Championship
um then then that's uh the good that's a
good thing and I think in the in the
future we'll probably see that um
uh online events will just be more and
more popular and um also we'll see what
happens with the next classical World
Championship who knows well okay we're
starting to get a bunch of questions
from the community and we're going to
dive in there and uh let the fans get
some I'm gonna I want to double click on
one other question you said from earlier
and then we're gonna dive into it you
said that you think that from a
classical time control perspective maybe
fish are random should be actually what
we're playing shorter time controls
traditional chess do you do you see a
future where you would want to be
competing in in slow Fisher random land
even slower than maybe the time controls
you've played so far
oh yeah for sure I'd love to see that in
the near in the near future I mean
that's really one of my main wishes for
for chess
coming up is to play slower fishing
random chess
um true there are going to be some
positions that are
um
just fundamentally a little bit boring
where you sort of have to follow
symmetry for the first most but I think
there are going to be so many
possibilities
um
as as well and I feel like the formats
that we have had now for Fisher random
they've been they've been exciting
enough but
if you have a little bit more time then
you actually have some more scope to
really dig into the position and to see
the sort of subtle differences there
there are between those positions and
sort of regular Jazz positions so I'm
all all for for that both from sporting
uh perspective and just for the from the
perspective of um of learning really
yeah I was just going to ask that you
you said the word sporting and I know in
the conversations you and I have had
that you feel like that's a big part of
why you feel faster time controls might
be more reflective of of a player's
all-around skills the sporting element
of real-time reaction solving it in real
time versus versus the computer at home
and you feel like Fisher random might be
the the evolution of really challenging
the sporting element of a top player I
guess summarize it makes sense all right
yeah that's good that's true that's true
yeah
the the sport of duck chess has become
popular I'm going to jump to our first
Community question from two of them our
own chesscom trim asks whether you've
played duck chess yet and then chess
weeb and chat wanted to ask whether
whether you're going to be playing in a
duck Chess Championship so have you
played duck chess and would you want to
become the first ever World duck chess
champion
I've played duck chess but I I watched
Hammer stream a little bit of duck chest
the other day I thought uh okay let me
try to sit through one game of this
um my first impression was uh
um was like Whoever thought of duck
chess just thought how can I
take chess and make it
just uh really boring uh it seems that
the games are just a lot
a lot slower it's harder to Checkmate uh
I guess there are some other weird
tactics but I just I just found it uh
incredibly boring but I know that other
people like it so that's that's fine
it's funny I actually had a similar
experience it was I found it painful not
boring I was playing IRL duck chess and
getting abused because the duck just sat
in the middle of the center ponds and I
could never figure out anyway uh slow
learner over here
um all right we're going to continue to
work through questions we have one from
Mommy game question for Magnus will we
see more from the maskinson uh Twitch in
the future the we know you you have uh
your own twitch channel right
um and you you've streamed from some of
the uh the office Bill club and what are
your thoughts on on that
well I have to say that your
um pronunciation is abysmal but uh apart
are you you're gonna call me out for
that I'm sorry I'm I'm also reading in
real time go ahead
uh yeah I think uh muskanistan will be
uh we'll be back
um that's for um that's for sure for for
different uh different events so um
has never been
has never been retired he's just been uh
been resting and he uh maybe he may be
coming back in the near near future or
at least in the medium future
Moscow descent moscanism yeah
okay all right
all right well there you have it and and
I'm gonna I'm gonna kind of quickly jump
to the next one from Anita drink which
wants to know what your plans are as a
streamer commentator and obviously you
just said maybe maybe a return of that
twitch Channel I know you have different
feelings about you know streaming while
playing
um what tell the fans how you feel about
that when when you enjoy it and when you
don't and what are your thoughts on
streaming while playing and or doing
other stuff
uh well I haven't done it too much but
I've I generally find it interesting and
I think sometimes if your brain is not
working so well it can be it can be you
useful because you sort of articulate
your your thoughts a little bit
um and I I have found it at times useful
um
but um
I think it takes a little bit of time
getting
getting used to for sure as for
commentating yeah
I like uh I like doing that I mean
that's something something that I um
occasionally enjoy a lot
got it cool all right next question from
TJ heezy wants to know uh I'm gonna kind
of summarize it whether there's anyone
you've yet to have a good Blitz session
against on chess.com that you'd like to
so kind of summarizing we know you've
thrown down against many but is there
someone out there that you would love to
throw down in an epic an epic you know
Bender of a blitz session throw it down
right here throw the gauntlet down
challenge them
yeah I mean there are there are a lot of
people that I haven't uh that I haven't
played
um
I mean alireza is probably the best best
player that I haven't that I haven't
faced in a
well actually I don't need to get all
the recipes again single in in the game
in a single game but also
I think it makes sense that uh if you're
going to play you know the very very
best the very toughest opponent at
the most exciting time controls
um then that's maybe something not
something you do casually maybe that's
something you do in a
sort of a more
um serious match
um yeah but um are you previewing
something maybe against guys like Hikaru
or Ali Reza Maybe
no we'll see we'll see uh but uh I I can
say like on in general uh terms I mean
something I'm
definitely interested in like I love
playing playing Blitz and playing
against some of the
well I mean the very the very best and
serious matches I mean there's nothing
more exciting than that
yeah I'll I'll say that um while we said
this is a show of many announcements um
there will be more announcements to come
and teas that of course we're working on
all we can to maybe have some fun fun
things like that that's all I'll say but
all right sticking on the comment of Ali
Reza and we want him to play more online
chess if he's watching uh I'm gonna I'm
gonna go to a question that you get a
lot but we're gonna ask it because I
think the fans just love hearing your
thoughts on it uh Moe underscore GE Moji
wants to know who do you feel is uh is
the strongest from these young chess
guys maybe your opinion changes from
time to time so I know I'm giving you a
question you've had forgive me for that
but your thoughts on you just threw down
against kukesh right you've seen what
nihal Soren's been doing Ali Reza
ferrugia your quick hit list on on some
of these young guys coming up who uh who
you have circled
well obviously uh Alvarez has Head and
Shoulders above
everybody else when it comes to
basically every every format
um
but um
yeah among among the others I wouldn't
say there's
um if if you're talking as an old
rounder I don't think there's anybody
who really stands out like
all of them have very distinct strengths
and and weaknesses which is
um which is to be expected from uh from
people at that stage in their career
people like alireza who are
who is so well-rounded in all or formats
and it's basically
[Music]
um
just one of the top guys means it's rare
to be that I say
as a teenager so for the others yeah a
lot of them are very
promising but as I said I wouldn't say
that like
as a no-brand or any of them really
stick out
okay makes sense all right a fun one
here to maybe round it off will we see a
Dr drunkenstein bot you've you've got
your main username and we know that the
the people who love to play Magnus Bots
will will probably get action on those
on chess.com but uh do you uh
do you I don't even know what the
question is Dr drunkenstein that's the
bot uh the the name on on the leeches
account you've used but any thoughts
about Dr drunkenstein making a chess.com
appearance
I don't know I haven't thought about uh
I haven't thought about that like one of
my friends uh asios he made a um bot
which um
the the reporter was partly based on
um on hyper bullet games so then you
could see a lot of you know like the
lafong some Queen C2 takes H7 and so on
so it would be fun to build a bot based
on my my drunken bullet games but um I
shouldn't say drunken though because I
was never I was never drunk I was at
most like
um a couple of drinks in in any of those
enjoying yourself yeah it would would be
fun
yep all right well there you have it
maybe we need to to get a bot not just
some Magnus at different ages
um I said before you joined I joke with
Andreas that my my son was super pumped
about you know he actually loved that he
could beat a bot Magnus Carlson even
though he couldn't get past five so
maybe we need a Dr drunkenstein bot with
with more personality so
um yeah but then that part is going to
be strong though I have to say it's
gonna be super strong that that's crazy
in fact maybe we make hybrid a hybrid
car Robot too and then fans can just
watch Magnus versus Hikaru Bots all day
and keep them keep them satisfied 24 7.
so all right all right I got one more
question
um because I know that some of the other
biggest names in the game have signed
with teams and we are bringing back the
protest league has anybody approached
you I know you haven't signed or
committed yet your thoughts on whether
you are are wanting to compete this year
and has anybody uh has anybody tried to
recruit you yet
yeah I've been contacted by a couple of
teams so I uh I actually
uh agreed to be on the list for a team
like a couple a couple hours ago
actually so that's pretty you want to
break the news and it's can you bring uh
tell us
okay I don't I don't know this so I'm
I'm super excited so I'm not promising
that I'll even play this season uh but
it's uh it's very much possible
okay well there you have it Magnus
Carlson is committed to a protest League
team I know I mean you did enjoy that
event right obviously we've all we've
all been torn up inside over the last
couple years that we haven't been able
to to do as many things together but now
the future the future is won and just to
speak of the PCO whether you play or not
you enjoy that that league right and
maybe give your thoughts on that type of
idea like Global team chess right an
online kind of Olympiad feel with free
agents your thoughts on the PCL and what
about that event that you like
yeah I enjoyed the the first season that
we played a lot with the uh Norwegian
team obviously there have been
Revelations about that
after the fact that I will not we were
gonna avoid all the controversial topics
we've been through for the last six
months but you did it you're right we
we've been through some stuff over the
last few months together you're right
that's uh okay but
um uh now I enjoyed the uh
uh the format a lot
um
uh I remember I mean speaking of
drunkenstein like
um that was one of the original uh
sessions like there was one one of these
rounds where you played Eight Games
Against One Division or something and I
did say that from a bar once having a
few drinks so that was that was a lot of
fun and I think I scored seven and a
half that time uh so yeah it's it's it's
uh it's a great um
great event uh find some camaraderie but
in in the team and um
that I guess now there's a
there's an in-person final as well at
least I I hope so
because that's what we're that's what
we're trying for with with with many of
our events in the future but yes so um
yeah we did it in 2018 and and 2019 and
and I definitely think that the PCL is
kind of built for for that type of live
kind of Esports thing so
yeah
all right man well we're gonna let you
go thank you to the to the community for
for questions Magnus thank you so much
for your time man obviously this is it's
a big day it feels uh it feels a little
bit like throwing the throwing the ring
into Mordor like it's done it's it's
been it's been a very long journey but
um for everybody this this uh means the
world to have you and and we're pumped
about the future so thanks for being
with us and uh for everything you do for
the game
no thank you so much and I'm definitely
excited for the all the possibilities we
have for for the future uh it's going to
be a great age for for chess I I believe
love it appreciate you man and uh let
you get let you get going
all right well that was Magnus Carlson
the world champion and I agree with what
he said this is uh it's uh it's a great
day for the for the future of Chess and
and there's a lot of opportunities ahead
and I I feel like I'm speaking for for
myself for him for a lot of people that
have been putting a ton into this that
it feels a little bit like a oh man and
again everyone's like oh well I thought
this happened once ago it didn't and
there's been a lot going on with it and
just to get here and to have the
opportunity for all of us to uh to
really start making plans about how to
improve everything together and and to
unify things and to create more
opportunities it means a lot and there's
plenty more to talk about coming up on
those topics around the corner I'm going
to be joined by the head of chessable uh
you know him as Garrett on social media
he's a Bit Sassy be joined by our VP of
content that's Sam Copeland haven't had
him on one of these before uh so much
more to talk about with
jessabilchess.com as well as things
right after that so don't go anywhere
the quarter four end of your state of
chess.com returns in a few
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
three two one
check it out
foreign
[Music]
thank you
we are back here rolling on with the
state of chess.com to bring this amazing
year for chess to a close it has been a
year and that that definitely was a an
interview with Magnus Carlson he broke
news right he's committed to a PCL team
I have no idea what team it is can't
wait to find out talked about his
opinions about the future of online
chess and thinks that more games being
played online as a sign of things to
come so anyway obviously lots to unpack
there I'm sure we'll be sharing it but
we have more to unpack you saw of course
the teaser at the break
we're going to be diving into what it
means for chessable and chess.com to be
working together uh this is going to be
a fun one I I'm super excited to talk
about uh some announcements we're going
to bring you some discounts on the
chessable library some flash sales
happening because of this merger there
will be perks for the chess.com premium
users in the future of course there's
going to be chess.com integration uh
which means you know recommended and
catered courses I feel like Eric and I
you know maybe we were a little nervous
to start the show we didn't want to over
speak or over promise so we didn't talk
a lot about the product stuff but we've
been putting a ton of thought into that
of course that's a big part of why we
want to do this is to help everyone get
the access they need for whatever their
level of knowledge and motivation is to
improve its yes and of course you're
going to see more courses made by your
favorite chess authors and now your
favorite chess streamers right Two
Worlds become one and on that note let's
bring two two guys together for one
interview we are are joined by by
Garrett uh the he's the head of
chessable and you know him you know them
from a lot of of things he's on social
media and leading the way for the
chessable team and then we have Sam
Copeland our our VP of content who helps
guide so many things these two guys are
the perfect two to bring together to
break this down
Garrett I I want to start with you uh I
know you have a long list so I have to
tell you just pick one thing like Eric
what are you most excited about for your
community the chessable community in
welcoming the chess.com users uh in this
coming year
um can we already start breaking uh
chess.com streamers uh doing a courses
well it will happen we've been teasing
it just don't say which ones yet but
okay so that's what you're most excited
about is the streamers and and bringing
their fan base adjustable
yeah I mean that's one of the big things
right there's a few you know uh teachers
of the internet that uh um can um can do
amazing stuff uh for our community and I
think actually like they can do
something amazing for the chess.com
Community which is share their knowledge
and and that's why we built the platform
and and uh and I'm just really excited
about those guys and girls coming over
to uh adjustable and to uh to start
teaching on our platform
yeah I love we're gonna we're gonna I'm
gonna keep the fans waiting for a little
bit longer because I want to ask Sam the
similar high level question first Sam
you're a guy you're you're you know
you're a chess master yourself you're a
chess educator you do your own content
your content for chess.com but you're a
chessable fan right you've been a fan of
chessable what they've been doing for a
long time so as a guy who's been helping
guide the ship for chess.com what are
you most pumped about as far as
connecting with and integrating uh with
with the products and and the courses
that chess.com has sorry the chessable
has offered
I am so excited about this in so many
ways uh Garrett and I got to connect a
little bit this week and uh one thing he
shared with me is that I'm one of the
first 1000 members on chessable so I've
been around uh for a long time on the
platform and have been enjoying and
using it
um and I'm a huge fan of the authors and
courses that are available and working
on the content site on chess.com I'm
super proud of the different types of
content that we do I was just looking up
right before this how many people have
taken our course on learning to play
chess and it's uh 7 million and just
over two hundred thousand so so many
people have come in and taken that
course appreciate that content
um and and we had that course even and I
think about 10 languages now
and there's a lot of other content that
we provide we just launched a big course
with 50 introductory opening lessons on
basically every opening there is so you
can get a quick introduction but we've
never really been able to serve the
improving Community the uh that really
wants to take their game to a next to
the next level the way that Garrett and
the team at chessable have and I'm so
excited that we can kind of bring this
together and we really have a great home
that complements all of the introductory
content that we have for Learners and
the other kinds of Broad and really fun
content that we do that'll really let
people take their game to the next level
I think it's a perfect compliment
you're not even talking about this for a
long time we'll have to save save that
because it would go to we're blue in the
face but okay let's bring up our talking
points again about what we're going to
be doing you know we're going to have
we're going to have discounts right
we're gonna do some flash sales but
Garrett you know everything Sam just
said in talking about the chess.com
lesson library and how awesome it's been
to reach such a large community he
mentioned some huge numbers but one of
the things that has failed is we haven't
had the model that gives back directly
to the author and to the Creator uh and
you know we've had a different type of
thing the all-inclusive Diamond
membership and now now it's going to be
something that is not just awesome for
chess improvers but directly supports
the people in the chess community that
they love the the best coaches the best
creators that they like so even though
we're going to talk about discounts and
sales
what what can you tell us about what
chessable does for Professionals in the
community can you give us some some
secret Financial numbers like how much
money has chessable paid out to creators
here over the last few years
can I put you on the channel
hr's yelling at me just tell it tell
everybody how much money the creators
have made
I think we can give a rough number here
um Chesterville has paid out over 7
million US dollars to creators since uh
we started
um we're really proud of that that's
something that we made part of our
mission very early on
um
we want authors and creators unjustable
to make money and one of the problems I
think there that existed in the Chess
World is that if you weren't a
professional player you had to go teach
and uh if teaching wasn't a thing then
maybe you could publish a book or
something but you know chess books
didn't really bring in a lot of money
for anybody and uh on chessable that's
different we have a um a really great
community of people who are interested
in improving and who are interested in
in buying courses and um we've made a
library with the help of our authors
that now serves you know well over 700
000 enthusiasts and uh hopefully with
the help with chess.com we can grow that
tremendously as you as Sam already
mentioned um you know you guys have a
huge community of Learners chessable
serves the improvers and I think now
that our two companies are going to
merge into one big family our
communities can come together and we can
bridge that Gap with our product
offering and that's really exciting
because that's going to help so many
more authors and creators in the chess
space find new audiences and and earn a
living because that's one of our biggest
uh you know goals as chessable is to
help more professionals like stay in the
game and that way we can help grow the
game
I love that and I uh if you didn't see
me put you on the spot there I apologize
but I I didn't know that number over
over 7 million and I uh I know of some
of the some of the you know the highest
earning and I can tell the world they
aren't necessarily the biggest names in
chess which I want to speak to the
chess.com community and let Sam take it
because we have we have so many amazing
top bloggers right we have so many
people who are creating content Sam for
the community that is super valuable and
awesome but we're doing it on chess.com
only because that's where a lot of the
users were and everyone who creates
wants it to be appreciated right by
those who love you know the the topic
that we're sharing together and so now I
think it's not just the big names and
it's not just the Anish giri courses and
I'm a trolling Niche Geary as much as I
can right it's it's every Creator uh who
may not be um one of the most famous
recognizable faces in the community so
Sam before we talk about some of the
most famous recognizable communities and
I promise we'll say next what are your
thoughts on that all the creators we
have on chess.com your bloggers your
video courses all those things getting a
chance to to contribute to chessable
just so exciting
um you know just from a personal
perspective as someone who obviously
with the people here has been making a
living in chess for a long time first
through private lessons and such when I
got into that and started writing on
chess.com I joined the blogging
Community the blogging Community was my
end to working for just by the way
that's how we are just creating content
yep sorry Sam that we hired Sam because
Sam was one of our best bloggers in the
community and I've reached out to him
and was like hey man do you want to join
us for this chess kit event and then it
blew have we ever told that story sorry
I get excited it's been a lot of years
go ahead
uh yeah absolutely I I remember I was
staying with Sean McCoy our head of
support at the world open and uh I was
uh I don't know about you guys when I'm
playing a tournament my mind just
wanders because you're at the board for
six hours it's hard to focus uh I was
thinking how could people cheat and I
talk to Sean afterwards I was like I'm
gonna write a blog on how to cheat at
just.com or how to cheat at chess and
that'll take off and that was my biggest
blog
that's not a topic people cleared 100
000 reads so I I really tipped a lot of
people off and it fed that straight into
a job so I think that was a great
strategy uh teaching people how to cheat
at chess uh yeah anyway
it's been incredible you know coming
through that space and being able to you
know get into chess and making a living
through this but that was really really
a rare opportunity and now what
chessable does is it offers to the
people who love creating content all the
bloggers that we have on chess.com that
opportunity you know that's not just
something like where I got really lucky
at an early stage when there wasn't a
big ecosystem to get involved in you
know now this is something for all of
the coaches that we have on chess.com
all of the bloggers the people who've
created articles and write news and uh
and just love creating content
they can now get in there and just do
whatever they want and I think that
Garrett and I will be so excited to see
the directions that people want to take
it courses that you know are super
Innovative uh we've seen so much
creativity in the community of creators
at chess.com on on YouTube and other
places and I think that bringing that
over to chessable will be really
exciting and in terms of names I think
you've been talking to a number of
different people uh who are creators
that have been working with just.com for
a while that are really interested in
creating courses on chessable uh Levy
Rosman uh Dottie noraditsky bowtes
sisters chess bras uh James Canty and so
many more people a lot of people
reaching out to us and they're just very
excited about getting involved with
testable creating courses and taking
ideas that in a lot of cases they've had
for a long time for you know this is
something that I'd really like to to get
out there this I think would be a great
book great course you know and now this
is a an opportunity for them to to bring
that over to chessable
you stole my thunder a little bit you
because you're good at what you do you
just threw right into it I was gonna I
was gonna tease it up by asking by
asking Garrett to pick if there was one
person in the world that he personally
wanted to make a chessable course who
would it be uh but I now I know the
answer it's the guy right in the middle
of that image and by the way I wouldn't
be showing them on this image
if they hadn't if they hadn't agreed
this um we we don't use their likeness
unless they agree so it is my job and I
have had a lot of conversations so
Garrett you take it away help Hunter you
to see these commitments this isn't just
like a tease these are commitments to
make courses in the year of 2023 by
these authors as well as the ones Sam
mentioned chess bras James Canty and so
many more Garrett Garrett make sure you
don't fall out of your chair when you
show your excitement for this
yeah
um I'm extremely excited but I know also
the whole we've been getting so many
requests from the chessable community
right and and and I think
once the chest.com community and family
figures out that chessable exists and
that we we have this platform where you
can learn and dive more deeper into
chess uh they're going to want to see
courses by Levy Rosman and and the both
as sisters but also by you Danny and and
so I'm really excited about that and I'm
especially excited about you know the
number one uh YouTube phenomenon that
Levy Rosman coming to chessable because
he's clearly the most requested author
on on chessable um and we've had to wait
a long time to get them to confirm a
course but um now that that's happening
in 2023 I can't wait for that to come
out because
he's an absolutely fantastic
Communicator yeah he speaks to people
that love chess but also in a way that I
think makes people more excited to
actually learn about Chess and so I
can't wait to see what he can bring on
chessable as part of a you know like an
offering that we have there with him
creating a course so that's really
exciting um but um one of the things I
wanted to highlight
um is that right now we're talking about
streamers we're talking about titled
players like you know Levy Rosman is an
international Master chess Danny you're
an international Master it says Jess I
think Sam you're also a title player so
I want to highlight that chessable isn't
a place that is just for those people
it's you don't have to be a super strong
player to create a successful chessable
course you can be a club player with a
really good idea for content and if you
put together something that is
educational that is well thought out and
Etc it has a real chance of success in
our Marketplace
um and uh one of those great examples is
um we have this course called the
Checkmate patterns manual which was
created by a Belgian Club player
um named RAF missultan
um on chessable his username is Crafty
RAF he created this course which is like
one of the best most comprehensive
courses on all the Checkmate patterns
that exist and uh it was a fan favorite
on our site like really early on then we
asked International John Bartholomew the
co-founder of chessable to do the video
presentation for it and then it became a
best-selling course and so what's
amazing to me about that story is that
RAF decided I need this for me and I can
CR and and since I need this for me I'm
going to create this for the community
I'm going to publish it in the
marketplace and uh people pick that up
and bought it and then supported it and
then as soon as uh John came and like
filmed the videos for it that course
became even more of a success and RAF
makes you know a a good living off of
that course and and uh and that's
amazing because I can't you know really
think of any examples in the Chess World
where people create educational content
and become teachers for others while
making a living off that off that kind
of thing and so
um if there's more of you chess
enthusiasts out there you know and you
think you have an original idea then
Jessica welcomes that and and that's I
think
slightly different from let's say like
the traditional chess publishing
business where it's mostly Grand Masters
or maybe International Masters
publishing uh and teaching and here I
think uh it's this this lovely
combination of super high level top
level players we have courses by Magnus
Carlson and anishagiri but we also have
these types of unique courses by Club
players who just really thought about
like what they would like to learn
themselves and then they create that
I love that so much so much I mean
honestly it
it's it's the the reason we did this
honestly and I think it's probably the
biggest value and of course Magnus
playing in events and the future of us
having the best players Under One Roof
and there's so many other things but
this opportunity for all the motivated
Learners in the Chess World is is simply
phenomenal so thank you for touching on
that we we have a bunch of community
questions so I'm going to throw to you
Sam this isn't a normal state of Chess
where we have a full segment dedicated
to not just product but every product
we've released every month we kind of
put together a quick Board of some of
the some of the highlights and things
that have been released over the last
few months so Sam I'm gonna let you
quickly run through
um our our you know our year in review
you know releasing the app the the clock
app maybe just quickly run through this
so we can get to more Community
questions and what do you feel like we
want to highlight for the chess.com
users and our quick product segment here
yeah there's just uh so much that has
just come out or is very soon to come
out that's really exciting a lot of
people will have received the year in
review email
um our most common question on social
media right now is when am I getting
mine so I think in the next two to three
days anyone who hasn't yet received it
you should get it
I I'm also waiting so I think we're
we're in the same uh Camp as everyone
else but
the year interview email is uh has made
a bunch of progress this year I think we
had fun with it last year but the design
team crushed it this year it's a huge
data crunch to pull all that data for so
many millions of users but it's going
out it's really fun I see people sharing
it already and you should get yours very
soon I got mine yesterday I want to see
awesome awesome you're the first one
here on this call there you go yeah all
right nice we've got a a new uh chess
clock app as well it's already on
Android go refresh that if you haven't
checked it out or download the chess
clock app if uh if you don't have it new
color themes totally new UI a lot of
settings really fun I'm running it and
just absolutely loving it everything I
wanted in a test clock app it's going to
be on iOS very soon
yes
there you go I think you were using it
in LA with uh chess boxing as well right
yep that's right it's gonna be fun all
right go ahead keep going
so we've released game review on uh on
our mobile apps
um got a bunch of things that are coming
to uh to game review I'll mention some
of the stuff at the end
uh as well right here
um I don't know about you guys but uh
I'd be playing on mobile I'd play a good
game and then I'd go load the game on
web to see if I got a brilliant move uh
with the uh most up-to-date algorithm so
now you don't have to do that it's uh
the same algorithm on uh mobile as it is
on web and there are a bunch of updates
coming to game review that we're calling
game review V2 some of them are already
available including just uh improved
uses of like arrows and squares to
illustrate Concepts the coach is talking
about and just a lot more uh dialogue
new uh classifications for what we
consider a blunder
um what do we consider maybe a missed
opportunity a lot of this stuff is
already in beta so if you're interested
in contributing uh on game review go to
the Beta Club sign up give us feedback
we'd love to have it I think early
January we're going to be really fully
out with game review V2 so that's
something to play around with and look
forward to uh right there
and then we've released I think I
mentioned a moment ago 50 opening
lessons every single opening basically
now has a mini course that's available
uh that you can check out in our
chess.com lessons product and very very
soon I think we've already teased this a
few times we have how I became a
five-time world champion a course with
this shionanda coming out that's going
to be like five hours of content uh with
Danny you and vishy Diving deep on his
career all kinds of insights honestly
yeah that was awesome the uh one of the
coolest moments of my life being able to
sit there with someone who I'm born and
raised a childhood Phantom to go over
his career and uh wow you you're not
going to want to miss that content sorry
Sam you queued me so I said it and then
I'll just finish and say there's also
updates coming to classroom and Library
too for those who don't know
um they should they should be uh
checking those things out Sam I only
want to keep rolling now and I'm going
to jump into the Community Q a because
we've got some great ones and I want to
I want to focus on some of them that are
coming to Garrett from the chessable
from the chessable side fans fans here
just getting just getting to know or for
the first time having a direct line to
you Garrett so we'll try to keep these
answers short so we can get to many of
them
um I already know the answer to this
something you teased it Ben Ben's bro
wants to know will Fabiano do a course
yeah he's already confirmed and working
on one
great I was hoping you could say it
because I knew he already told me yes uh
next one joking joke jokey jokestinator
wants to know who makes the epic art
covers at chessable he's a fan
yeah that's Adam
um Adam Ledford
um and uh he's all over Twitter so um um
just go look him up there he's got a ton
of artwork up there um he does all of
our illustrations and artwork covers for
the lifetime repertoire series and I
think that's what is being referred to
because we have this kind of like
superhero artwork for the lifetime
repertoires and some of the other uh
courses and it's very recognizable it's
very much Adam's style
um he actually got his break
um creating some artwork for some uh you
know really big YouTube streamers and
then we we asked him to start working
with us and create covers but we have a
team of designers uh a couple of other
people who also do really amazing
artwork and I gotta send a shout out to
our uh our art director Juan capitoni
because um he also does amazing
illustrations and uh has produced so
many really fun uh covers that that are
really just bring brings a lot of like
joy and kind of fun to chess because a
lot of chest covers are so serious and
we we want it to you know bring a little
bit more light-heartedness into that
into that feeling of like studying so
that it's because it's about Joy like
justice we play chess for fun we study
chess for fun of course everybody wants
to win but in the end like uh it's just
so much fun to to learn more about the
game and so we tried to reflect that in
our artwork
I love it I'm going to answer some of
these quickly so the community knows we
got them M zungu 9-4 wants to know will
there be a feature to load personal
games from chess.com into chessable for
comparative practice yes will it be
available in a month no but yes that
feature is coming and it's one of the
coolest things that we're excited to do
is those Direct Connect for all the
users on chess.com to get uh to get
their games instantly uploaded and all
the uh get access to all the adjustable
features you're in the house wants to
know will chess.com Partners be able to
stream chessable yes as of yesterday uh
any nhs.com streamer should could and is
probably probably already planning on
streaming whether it's their own
chessable course or
um or maybe again Anish Geary's course
if they if they happen to have forgotten
to delete it they might stream a niche
anisha's Court I don't know
um but yes drivers can do that
the the um the uh let's see tritlow
tritla wants the noble adjustable
content be fully integrated into
chess.com app right now the plans are
for them to remain separate partly
because they should be separate
chessable is uh is its own Community its
own uh very powerful brand
um and very focused on what it's doing
for those uh improvers out there super
motivated to take their their game to
the next level and chess.com's UI if you
haven't already noticed
um Eric and I've said this a lot the
crisis we've always had is we we're just
for everyone there's a lot going on on
chess.com so why why squeeze more into
it why not keep it separate and let um
let it be very clear for users how to
find it
um
wants to know when will Danny make a
chessable course
Sam when am I doing he's already in the
work
it's already I gotta take a look at that
2023 calendar uh I think there were some
discussions already uh and uh maybe we
can bring forward some of your best
blunders something like that best
blenders that's what we need or or
dubious opening so whatever people are
into
um all right how nice to get an
advantage with the varisov
how not to get God I'm now is this just
Rose to any show what else you got Sam I
mean geez uh the how about I've only got
two roasts how to get your queen trapped
on each one okay
um Garrett so so awesome to have you man
and what a pleasure and we're super
excited about this Sam thank you so much
for bringing the Heat and bringing the
roast uh if you've got more later
um and uh we'll we'll be diving into so
much more and this was uh this was a lot
of fun so I'm gonna let you guys go get
us to a break before we we get to our
final segment so thank you for being
here and chessable and chess.com for the
win
let's go let's go all right that was
that was Garrett and Sam and those two
guys are gonna be spending a lot of time
together and I think it's I think it's
going to mean a lot of good things for
the chess Community
um and not just the the years but just
in the immediate months to come what
what is going to happen hooking up
chessable with chess.com for those who
are super motivated to get better it's
going to be mind-blowing so all right
next we're going to be joined uh by uh
by a guest to talk about things
happening for the community speaking of
mind-blowing as you know we reached 100
million members what are we gonna do
about it it's gonna be awesome and who
is joining our company as our new head
of community you may you may know him um
and uh he'll be he'll be starting
January 1. he's going to join us to talk
about what that means and a lot of the
things that we have around the around
the corner so don't go anywhere it's the
second to last segment before the AMA
for our quarter four end of year
stateofchess.com
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
time
we are back the state of chess.com
continues if you're just getting here
which some of you are because we're a
peak viewership you missed so much we've
been we've had interviews with Magnus
Carlson breaking news and a ton a ton
more that we've we've jumped into if
those announcements are big enough for
you then then I guess the announcement
is that our intern is no longer in
charge of announcing big announcements
because we feel like they were pretty
big and there's been a lot of topics
we've gotten into there's there's still
more to come uh all right well on that
note we uh we had a big thing happen
this last week which wasn't an
announcement we thought it was going to
be the major headline of the show
there's been a lot else too but we
crossed a hundred million members
registered that's that's crazy that's a
lot and it was a big thing that happened
um for us um and and it happened in live
fashion it was a pretty emotional thing
and and represents the hard work by by
so many here at the company but also the
the Chess World is popular and growing
and all of you here are a part of that
story uh speaking of that story Eric and
I sat down and and told the story of
chess.com the The Rated PG uh too long
didn't read version but it was still
long it was still about an hour and the
full video was on YouTube but uh we
wanted to share a little bit uh of uh of
uh that conversation with a few
highlights in this video about the
history of chess.com I remember the
moment where I was like oh my gosh we
have a Grand Master on our site he's
like kicking everyone's ass he's like
he's just winning all of his games what
super strong Grand Master is this
it's not a secret
it was somebody cheating and we're like
oh my gosh how are we going to deal with
this it's hard to explain the whole
process but immediately right then we're
like this is going to be make or break
for our future we have to invest here
and immediately started hiring like
statistician built an amazing team
around this and we've invested so much
time and money and resources just to
protect this game that we love at this
time I'm a couple years behind Eric so
I'm not thinking about the Myspace I
would start thinking of Facebook so I
also went and bought chessface.com and
chest face live these are just don't
know I think I bought chestbase.com okay
can we just can we just cut that from
this video that I thought at one point
that was a domain name worth owning when
all the other chess companies out there
at the time and there were more than
there are now
um back then they all had logos of you
know Kings where they had Knights or
whatever and we were like we're doing
the pawn and the reason we're doing the
pawn is because we're doing chess for
everyone
it was a lot of fun we got into a lot of
a lot of things in that video if you
haven't checked it out yet it's at our
at our YouTube channel
um I won't tease all the things Eric and
I talked about because
um it's too many but
so many so many stories that went in
including the purchase of really in
hindsight cringy and and dumbass can I
say dumbass it's a PG-13 show domain
names that I bought in the in the early
days so all right well the community is
no longer what it was then it's 100
million members and we
we have a new person joining the company
who's going to be our head of community
uh going to be facing some different
problems than we did when we were asking
questions like how do we go from 100 100
you know uh users to ten thousand more
like how do you manage a a nation of 100
million people but with us now is
international Master Casa Corley who
will be joining chess.com on January 1st
as our new head of community Casa super
excited to have you and how pumped are
you about uh stepping into these shoes
thanks Danny it's a really exciting time
in the Chess World right I mean we have
uh just a really great opportunity here
to really grow the game and and
ultimately kind of transform the vision
for chess fans all around the world so
it's I'm really thrilled to be a part of
it
um I'm excited about meeting uh meeting
people where they're at I think there's
so many different types of Chess fans
there have been so many new entrants
into this this Arena and a very short
period of time and we're just looking to
keeping that going in a really
incredible way so uh yeah I'm really
excited about it
are you are you overwhelmed by it I mean
I said it's it's a different kind of
role than than stepping into something
that uh that is uh it's we're still
young Scrappy hungry but it's it there's
a lot going on right what what do you
feel like you have on your list as far
as stepping in
um as someone who's gonna continue to
work with with all the amazing things we
already have going and what are some
things you'd you'd like to kind of
highlight about that
yeah so uh first of all I think that
there are really awesome uh Community
activations that ultimately uh uh we
have we have the potential to really
meet people where they're at uh one of
them I actually wanted to highlight uh
is something we're going uh that people
should be aware of uh which is our
classroom feature and we're actually
going to uh kind of amplify that and
give that a little bit more love because
I think a lot of people don't know
enough about it yet and we're gonna have
a monthly uh kind of rollout we're gonna
call it Casa's classroom where we
essentially have really teachable
content where we engage the community
where we
um you know we we really get things
going in a way that's really exciting
for people
um then there's there are other mediums
as well besides the um there are other
mediums where we can engage with people
uh we do have a very growing uh Discord
uh channel that you know has uh you know
is really has a lot of potential and we
can actually set up these like fireside
chat kind of thematics that we really
hope will just bring a lot of people
into the tent essentially and um if you
don't know already you can actually link
your uh chess.com account to Discord
which
um I don't think many people are aware
but it's it's kind of an exciting thing
so you're aware of the things that
actually happen
yeah I learned it recently
okay I've got my Twitch account linked
but I didn't know we could link the
Discord so shame on me okay awesome well
let me ask you a hard-hitting one then
because you mentioned okay exciting time
for chess we're going to be doing all
kinds of things and yeah I think you
said it well meeting different chess
fans at the level they're at and it's
not just the level they're at but the
level of Engagement they're at right
because there's different types of Chess
fans those who watch shows those who
want to casually watch games only those
who only want to play right and I think
I love how you said that because that is
our goal is to give people an experience
that's joyful for them but what's not
joyful is cheating and I I'm gonna jump
to like a topic that you know you and I
have conversed a lot about we mentioned
it in this video we talked about the
first time someone cheated on chess.com
part of your role is not going to be
oversee cheat detection there's a lot
going on there but to help manage you
know how we how we approach this new
world where cheating
has always been taken seriously but I
think the Optics
um and and the perception and and you
know frankly the microscope is bigger
than ever as it should be because
there's more at stake there's more money
on the line right and there's more
professionals who really care about that
so what do you one two questions I know
that was a long-winded way to ask a
question but one do you remember the
first time you were cheated against if
there's a funny story there and two what
do you see as your role as the head of
community as a title player to kind of
Shepherd chess.com's Future Vision of
dealing with cheating and dealing with
how we navigate professionals and
amateurs alike when it comes to
educating them about about not doing bad
things
yeah a few many things to say there I
think uh the first thing I'll say is I
actually uh have not ever really caught
someone red-handed or anything like that
so it's really it's really uh yeah I I
I've tended to uh really see and believe
the the best in people
um and maybe uh that's why we hired you
right there go ahead it's uh it's been
uh it's been an interesting Journey um
uh to say the least uh as a player
myself uh quite an active player
um I do completely empathize with
basically every tranche of player that
engages with this in some way and I
think uh as everyone really knows uh now
that you know online chess is is really
taking center stage in many ways we
heard uh even Magnus speak about the
entertainment value the joy of the game
um the even the numbers uh with what we
saw with uh uh Magnuson hakaro um over
the week over the weekend
um we're in an environment now where the
stakes are just really high and because
the stakes are high uh you know there's
a responsibility there on everyone to be
better and so
um I think having sort of the player's
perspective in mind
um I'm I'll be able to kind of empathize
empathize liaison work with players
through some of these issues as they
come up and also in certain situations
we have to think about responsibly
handling
situations where there where there might
be an issue right like at the end of the
day not not all issues not all cases are
the same
um there are factors that we may need to
lean into in certain cases over over
others and um and you know adjudicating
uh these situations is really a delicate
balance and so
um I I'm not the the sole actor here but
of course uh leveraging um all of the
stakeholders and coming to decisions
that you know we feel really good about
based upon
um the perspectives in the room is going
to be important
I love that I mean
answers like that you can be the only
stakeholder as far as I'm concerned I'm
willing to retire when it comes to this
department and and get out of the get
out of the Limelight of any cheating
scandals not sure if you've heard about
anything going on this year we won't get
a joke so anyway I very very well said
and and I agree right I mean navigating
navigating you know different
stakeholders different situations and
also making sure that at the core of
what we're saying to fans which is this
chess event matters and it matters not
just because of what's at stake and the
best players are playing but because the
games are being played cleanly and
fairly and and the players understand
that and the fans know that I think it's
important for the buy-in because it can
be entertaining but if at the core
um we're not we don't have control over
that situation it could get away from us
right and so I think that
um you know speaking for someone who you
know is in your shoes and and now you're
taking those shoes I I think that you
said it really well and and um
I can't wait to see uh to see how those
things go so a casa I wanna I wanna
pivot now to talking about one of the
most exciting things you're stepping
into which uh you talked about Casa's
classroom you know we've we've now
touched on the on the cheating thing but
the first big event that the community
is going to be leading to start the year
is going to be our celebration of the
100 million member Milestone right and I
you know I've got the board up here and
and wanna I'll ask you to kind of sound
off on what you're most excited about we
we know the history we launched in May
of 2007 on December 16th we hit it so
what are we doing about it casa take it
away right we're doing 100 hours of live
streams streamers and and all kinds of
special events in merch what are you
most pumped about uh that we're going to
be doing come February for this event
I'm just really looking forward to the
Celebration I think you know there's so
many there's so many people uh that have
been a part of this journey and I think
over the course of the hundred hours
you're gonna get it get a real taste of
a lot of the people that have been a
part of this journey um and again it's
not the end of the journey it's just the
beginning but really just to appreciate
um to appreciate this this path to
essentially uh showcase a lot of you
know the people that have been a part of
this journey and that fans enjoy and so
on I think is really what I'm looking
forward to and uh
um hopefully staying awake for uh most
of it I don't know that's going to be
100 challenges
I will be we'll be we'll be watching
some um we'll be a part of some I love
what you said everyone who's been a part
of this journey I mean we're going to be
bringing on people who probably even
don't even know they're invited yet
right David David preuss original
co-director of content in some of the
early shows we did we're good anyone
anyone who's done things I wanted say
like the chest bras and all of our
streamers and and so many of the people
who were not just a part of maybe
creating content who the community might
recognize but also in the background so
it's going to be a 100 hour straight
stream of uptime that is our celebration
for 100 million members and yes there
will be merch giveaways I will also be
bringing back some OG uh formats and
shows that I've wanted to do for a long
time uh not just bullet brawls but some
other stuff so for uh fans who might
remember that uh I'm gonna I'm gonna
have a blast stepping in on that on that
as well Casa what what are we having you
do during that because if if I'm doing a
bullet brawls and doing some kind of you
got to step into and do some stuff so
you we got to have you take some of the
hours of that of that hundred hours down
yeah there's going to be some classroom
components going on as well um so you
can stay tuned for that
um there are definitely going to be some
rewards and so on
um I'm also keen on on getting some
fireside chat Dynamic going at some some
point as well
um yeah there's going to be a lot going
on so uh stay tuned
he doesn't know he'll be hosting the
whole thing okay chat trolling me uh
that's not true Trent that's not what we
agreed okay
um all right Casa well on that note
great great queue up from trim because
we've got some other questions from the
community get that out of here I'm um
you know Casa's hosting the whole thing
but all right
um concept we're gonna tee you up with
some questions we've got one from uh
capybara Queen BR wants to know how do
you think that the values can be
developed in communities and I I'm gonna
kind of say maybe the values you were
talking about and what do you what is
your thought on establishing and
developing values within within a
community
yeah I mean
so I think it's a it's important to wrap
it wrap it up within the context of
chess.com because I think I think there
are plenty of online communities across
the internet and we can talk about those
but let's talk about chess.com
specifically and I think you know
chess.com besides having so many uh
users right we've just crossed 100
million it's a really big deal
um there's so many different touch
points where we can meet you where you
are where maybe we're not we're not
always doing that yet right and so we
have amazing events that people love to
tune into and uh we have uh we have
great articles and and and and blogs and
and things that people can read and so
on
um I think there's a dynamic of kind of
live and re real-time components away
from events where we can engage with you
whether it's
um whether it's because you're
interested in improving your chess and
there's there's forms questions you uh
where where you're they're places where
your questions can be surfaced whether
there are again I'm I'm going to sound
like a broken record but I really am
keen on this far side chat Dynamic that
I think we can get uh whether it's in
disk or whether it's in the classroom
Dynamic
um
I think I think a community that's at
its best is going to have uh any level
of player really well engaged and I
think uh even through the course of this
show and uh you know we we had uh
adjustable folks on earlier that are now
with really chess.com folks
um you see that there are there are a
lot of title players in our in the
ecosystem and uh of course they get a
lot of shine but there are a whole lot
of other chess players as well and we
want you to feel like there's a place
you can go
um to engage uh when there isn't
necessarily A a broadcast uh that you're
tuning into and so we're really working
hard to make sure there's many different
places where you can engage uh with
people that are where you are um and
that's that's kind of one of the things
I'm going to be focused on quite a bit
in 2023
I love that I love that and I'll even
add a little bit of how do we establish
you know values as Casa said it starts
with we can't speak for the values of
other communities but what are
chess.com's values right we want be kind
be helpful and be relevant Eric and I
always say that right because being kind
is first and foremost think about what
you're saying and being helpful uh
meaning uh don't don't say things that
aren't helpful to people or the
conversation like we talk about with
chat in real time and then being
relevant I think is important too and
again I'm kind of speaking broadly and
but I think we have to establish what
are the values we want of our community
so I would even also throw it back at
capybara if there are values that you
bring Discord and these fireside chat
moments that cost is talking about are
your chances to to share them and and we
we want to make sure we continue to do
that because I think a healthy Community
has values that keep us guided and are
sort of our map what you know when it
gets dark right our Lighthouse when the
she when the Seas get rough and I I love
that question and we'll continue to to
work on that together
um all right
what does yeah
may I add one other thing to that as
well uh Danny please so when we're so as
a someone that's been playing chess
actively for over 20 years essentially
so much of the chess work I've done over
the course of my life has been basically
toiling and I I've always joked around
about it toiling in science or working
on my own and so on and that really
doesn't have to be the case anymore
right like right the the internet in our
chess communities have made it where
that really doesn't have to be the case
there are people that are also working
on chess thinking about Chess and just
having fun with it that you where and
you can there are places where you can
share ideas and I think now more than
ever is the opportunity for that so you
don't have to have this Dynamic frankly
that I grew up with uh so I'm really
looking forward to that I love that
evolving
I love that and it keeps people there
even when times get tough too because
you're sharing it right it's easier to
go through it when you're not going
through it alone so I love that um all
right let me uh there was that last
question we just had I'll quickly answer
it so we can move on to the next one you
get you can actually get an ad free
experience if you link your account on
Twitch to chess.com so we've got 8 000
plus viewers right now if you go to
chess.com and link your account uh and
you're a subscriber on Twitch you get an
ad free experience so even if you're not
a gold member let alone platinum or
diamond
being a subscriber on Twitch alone gets
you an ad free experience so that's one
thing uh there are also future things
coming and and we hope to kind of invest
further in that in that integration to
give more benefits but already that's a
reason to do it especially if you're a
subscriber to Twitch so all right
carrots and pizza is there a plan to
match players with the same opening
we're getting we're getting into the
Danny AMA section let me save that let
me save that for later because that's
not a that's not a community question
necessarily
um I want to say uh okay next one
Brandon atterberry wants to ask Casa the
verified program status I don't even
know if Casa knows that we tried the
verified program this year and we didn't
really find the community took to it but
let me ask you a a general question on
that what are your thoughts on that Casa
about creating experiences where some of
our users can choose to verify their
identity in a way to maybe take part in
tournaments or be a part of experiences
that that are um that are perks I guess
for for kind of like putting a little
more of like hey this is really matters
to me I'm not just an anonymous person
kind of potentially acting in ways that
uh that I wouldn't be accountable for
yeah so I I I was vaguely aware of uh
our the verified program but uh but not
not I mean not having gone great in
depth into it but I think when when
we're talking about uh
whether to have verified events or not I
and whether there's whether it needs
should be anonymity or not I think it a
lot of times depends on the type of
events and the and the size of the
communities the size of the the torments
you're trying to have I mean so the
short answer is it really depends um I
think you know in recent times uh if I
can just briefly the you know uh mention
the Twitter stuff that's been going on
you can see how there are there are
floors
we don't talk about Twitter you know but
no kidding go ahead
so um so I think I think there's a lot
of nuance to it it really depends on the
the size of the communities you're
working with and what type of people are
operating within those communities like
if you're if you're if you're in a
situation where there's maybe a
tournament or an event that's when it's
like where there's a relatively discreet
number of people uh maybe verification
has more value because everyone kind of
maybe wants to know each other and and
that that can really be something that
works if it's something where they're
like thousands of people or more than
that a lot of people really value their
anonymity so I think it depends on sort
of the size and the type of thing you're
trying to do
yeah I think that's a a great a great
answer right and I could add a lot more
to it as well as a guy who was a big
believer in creating the verified
experience and kind of being told by our
community that um it wasn't that
important to them we didn't have a lot
of people do it
um I think it was about 10 000 total
which is which is great for the ten
thousand who wanted to and and that's
more than people viewing the show I'll
just share that number
um but I think we thought it would um it
would be more embraced and I think that
there's something to revisit there maybe
down the road like Casa said maybe it
should be based on experience or the
tournament specifically at the time and
not kind of an all-exclusive thing
there's a lot to talk about in regards
to this and
um without opening the Twitter the
Twitter experience we're seeing too so
we'll uh we'll kind of we'll kind of
leave that where it is and Casa I think
on that note I'm probably gonna wrap up
our segment and leave you to uh to have
your day and enjoy the holidays because
this is uh there's some there's some I'm
gonna stick around and and and punt on
on some questions and have fun with the
community Community here a little bit in
real time but I just want to say super
pumped to have you I I can't wait to see
the the work we're going to do together
the work you're going to do and uh I
know I speak for the whole team on that
so any any final words before we let you
go
hmm uh I didn't have a prepare something
something prepared but I must say uh I'm
very excited for uh for what's uh what's
to come and um
happy holidays
thank you well that's all you need
sometimes so all right man happy
holidays to you and we're also excited
we will we will see you on many future
many future uh a day and uh and
certainly for that hundred hour stream
that we're excited to be doing so let
you go now and good luck in your first
classes classroom
thank you thank you stay tuned
all right well that was our new head of
community Casa Corley and a lot of
people asking Casa about streaming so I
guess I didn't see that we we didn't get
that question up but we'll let Casa
answer that later maybe Casa will be
streaming he's going to be doing Casa's
classroom so maybe tune into the first
one I'll say knowing Casa for the years
I have he is a he is a natural teacher
in a natural communicator and I think
anyone who Tunes in for the Casas
classroom and kind of takes part in a
fireside chat and asks questions you're
going to get some awesome responses and
he's a guy who's been coaching and
teaching chess players of different
levels for a long time along with
pursuing his own career so
um as a player I mean and uh anyway so I
think I think if anyone wants to see
more of Casa streaming and they let him
know that you might you might get your
wish and uh so go ahead and do it to get
your wish Community I'm gonna stick
around now it's time is it finally time
do I get to like just just like let my
hair down or maybe in some cases put my
wig on and just uh be my be myself and
answer answer direct questions from the
community I'm ready to do it
um I'm even gonna bring a chat in real
time I know we'll continue to feature
chat but I'm going to bring up chat in
real time too so I can I can answer
there as well
um
let's start with uh
I feel bad for carrots and pizza first
of all who puts carrots on pizza
right
I mean what are you doing there
um carrots and pizza so let's start with
carrots and pieces question because I I
I drove by it going 90 miles an hour
because I felt like it was uh it was a
broader question than for Casa so let's
bring back carrots and pizza's question
which is is there a plan to match
players with the same openings so
um
it's it's that's a yes and to that
question we we already have thematic
tournaments that you can play in Daily
chess right and so if you're looking to
practice an opening or get more get more
work done there you can do it I believe
we also have thematic uh tournaments in
in in Play Already meaning in the Live
Events um and if not that feature is
that feature is coming and you know we
would never manipulate the back end of
the pairing system to only pair you with
someone with that with the same openings
I think that would be kind of weird and
probably would end up having the reverse
effect but that is an interesting
feature if you could like set your
settings that you want to be paired
against people who also want to play
that opening that's an interesting
feature let's tag that to the first one
I'm going to ask Trim in our awesome
moderator Community to make a note of to
feed to Eric now it's an Eric problem
see how I do that I just like sign off
and say Danny thinks a good idea give it
to Eric throw it at Eric and then Eric
is the bad guy whether we do it or not
um I think that that's interesting
carrots and pizza much more interesting
than putting carrots on Pizza super
super hard pass on that that's going to
be a no for me dog big no for me dog all
right BJ h13 oh my God I'm going to read
my slack as the team brings questions
here
will we finally get a Danny after dark
the chest dad show that we've all been
waiting for
um who who still lets this guy control
feature jet bjh now uh I really enjoy
streaming for the for those of you out
there who are still following the twitch
uh dot TV slash Daniel wrench Channel or
in BJ hsk still subscribing month after
month and just giving me his his 4.99
even though I never stream there
um first of all thank you for that and
anyone who's ever watched my personal
streams knows I really do enjoy it I
also love teaching and I I think I'm
decent at it I love the process of just
communicating something to someone at
their level of understanding and it's
often therapy for me where I probably
say things I shouldn't say as a chief
chess officer but for some reason when
I'm on my own twitch Channel I feel like
I'm allowed to which isn't really true
but I do it anyway so Danny after dark
will come and when it comes it will be
rated R and when it's rated R it will
get wild
will it happen
um before I'm fired from this company
um I don't know BJ because it may take
that for me to to really let my hair did
so we'll see
all right Matt Incognito wants to know
can we get a weeklychess.com podcast
hosted by Danny Ranch that's a great
question we are very interested in the
future of podcasting content is that did
I say that in a cringy boomer enough way
yeah cringy Boomer succeeded right
unlock level cringy Boomer
um yeah I hear that podcasts are what
the kids are listening to these days and
so I would like to have a cast as well
can I put it in a pod what do you do
with your cast do you put it in a pot
and then people wrap it up okay
um we want to do that I know I don't
want to speak for Peter Dockers um good
friend of mine love that guy I know he
wants to do a podcast there's also the c
squared podcast Fabiano caruana and
Kristen chorilla stop what you're doing
and look up the c squared podcast by
Fabian Christian and and go give them a
subscription because they're awesome and
I love that podcast and yes there will
be there will be more chess.com podcasts
in the future
okay
at Grimmer four I love the product
questions is there a plan to allow a
library
on mobile app yes
and
um it's it's a feature we really feel at
its core is it's kind of for when we're
in serious improver mode I think of all
the features on chess.com Library works
with chessable super well for those who
don't know go to chess.com library now
you can organize your games you can make
favorites you can put your best games
you can you can organize games by top
players it's very similar to chess based
as far as having databases and files
that you personally curated then you can
analyze the game and then re-save it and
update it so it's it's a self-study tool
that is for serious learning and so
usually serious learning Grimmer 4
happens when you're on a computer right
and so I'm giving you the real insight
into our thought process it's not our
highest priority to bring to mobile
because it's
I think it's a feature that is still
going to be 95 used on web even when we
have it on mobile and that doesn't get
moved in our product roadmap because we
got a lot of awesome features we're
doing and our team is crushing it so you
feel me Doug right and so I do believe
there's a world of having files
accessible on your phone that can be
super helpful before a tournament game
never during a tournament game because
that's cheating
um but at the same time I think there
are other priorities for our mobile app
and other things and I'm kind of a
believer that maybe Library deserves its
own app at some point you know for those
who know about it they would download
and use it and then it's not kind of
bloating the regular app experience
right because there's a lot to do on the
chess.com app if you haven't heard
um and uh and so that's kind of how we
think about that so hopefully that
answers your question potjam night Danny
are you going to do stats on Cheaters
people band you mentioned how important
it is but every event has issues so
normally when we do state of Chess we
bring up our our report where we say
like this month we close this many
people for cheating close this many
people for abuse close this many people
for title you know title players for
cheating right so the answer is we are
doing all of those things I think that
unfortunately there are issues just like
there's issues with crime in the world
um and I'm not comparing cheating at
just to to murder or any in any way but
I am saying that like people do bad
things and then we catch them that doing
it and believe it or not we are closing
thousands of people every day for doing
it so there's issues but that's in no
way a reflection of our cheat detection
our processes our systems There's issues
because people choose to do those things
you've seen the movie Minority Report
when they try to let Tom Cruise predict
murder now you're messing with free will
which gets existential and metaphysical
and you can't mess with free will so I
kind of throw that question back at
potjam Knight because I believe there
was a tone I believe you had a tone with
me and your tone implied that we're not
doing enough for cheating and I don't
like that tone because that's not fair I
think people are cheating we're catching
them we're busting ass and we're
actually doing it better than anybody in
the world and have been for a long time
and we're going to continue to do it and
our investment in events reflects that
top players want to play it and they
feel pretty good about it and we're
going to continue to do that so if that
wasn't your tone I apologize for calling
you out but there's nothing we can do to
stop people from doing bad things and
we're going to continue to invest in it
so help me world help me tell people not
to cheat
and then I won't have to catch them next
question jokus and Nader are the more
cringe fobby are there more cringe Bobby
has commercials in the future I miss
those and I should and I want more I
agree
there should be more cringe moments with
Robert Hess and Fabiano caruana always
um I just saw a question in real time
from Boondock Striker that someone will
bring later we'll get we'll get to that
question about whether there's going to
be paid tournaments for under ratings
um because I have a good answer for you
so we'll get to you Boondock Striker
V verme when will duck chess come to
mobile that's a fantastic question
please everybody everybody go to
chess.com click on the little question
mark in the corner and submit that
question for Eric
just because he loves it um no jokes
aside I'm not going to do that to my guy
duck chess is built on a completely
different Tech stack to use our
terminology chess.com variants if you go
there where you can play bug house and
crazy house in fog of war and duck chess
it's it's it's a different team it's not
the same as as the mobile uh you know
Tech stack and language that we're
working on for IOS and Android and so
it's not as simple as when we build
something amazing to the variants that
we just plug it into Mobile and it's
almost easier to do its own app and then
you wonder okay is there enough of an
appetite for it so
Doug chess on mobile frankly chess.com
doesn't own duck chess Just Like Home
doesn't own chess right anyone can do
that and so we have a big community and
I think we try to invest in the best
product of Chess that's that's what our
business is on but we don't own chess we
don't know any of the variants and
anyone can make amazing games and apps
and they should right I I think that we
try to have the best product for chess
we try to be the best place for people
to learn the best place for people to
play because nobody owns this incredible
game that we love been around since 600
A.D nobody owns Duck chess but there is
an inventor of it but even he I don't
even know if he owns maybe he does but
maybe he should be the guy who should
invent the who should who should do the
duck chess app because we're just trying
to have the best community and the best
place to play duck chess but I don't
know that we can possibly be the company
who makes like every every app for every
type of Chess variant so maybe everyone
email the guy who invented duck chess
and ask him to make an app Eric will be
happy that I said that instead of him
you're welcome Eric
um okay 512 5 rock climber Danny is
there any chance you'll be creating kids
content either on chess.com or chess kid
me personally
oh man I missed the days do I do I
can you guys not tell that I have a
little pent up energy when I get on
these shows you don't think I miss the
days of just being a content creator
I'm trying to get canceled as a chief
chess officer if you haven't learned I'm
trying to get sued I'm trying to get
fired this year you know we crossed 100
million members yours truly is getting
sued for 100 Mil
I feel 100 years old we're doing 100
hour Stream So the sooner my life gets
better and I'm doing content the better
for all of us and I love doing kids
content I love I love teaching I love
doing videos so uh answer your question
as soon as I can I will do more content
and doing kids content will will be on
the top of that list so anyway there you
go
um
Matt Incognito at chess can we get
chesscom event in UK Maybe
I don't know why not oh wait I I skipped
Boondock Striker I want to answer this
one
um
we have a ton of USCF online rated
tournaments Eduardo Carla Carlos if you
haven't joined the club we have Monday
Wednesday Friday go join the club so
sorry I skipped ahead we're going to
Boondock Striker here we go uh Danny is
there any chance we can get paid
tournaments for under 2200 1500 and 1100
players so Carlos's question kind of
relates to that there are events that
matter not with prize and money
happening all the time uh the USCF
online rated ones are are is an active
club and you might want to join those
I would say that we're already doing
tournaments with under prizes you just
have to stream Boondock Striker Arena
Kings is that event
um
trim if you can remind me what our
prizes are for arena Kings in our in our
in our slack channel here we can we can
bring it up in real time but we have
underprices and to be fair uh I think
that there are we have so many millions
of members six million daily active
people log into chess.com to play chess
and we already have a lot of cash prize
tournaments for for title players and
streamers adding those along with the
level of quantity that we would be
staring down is kind of a daunting task
because of one particular topic which is
cheating right and so what did we try to
do we tried to create the verified
program because everyone always says
they want what you're saying Boondock
but then when push comes to shove if we
say that we're gonna do money
tournaments for verified users which by
the way we're doing okay so we have
money tournaments for verified users
still going no one wants to get verified
we have Arena Kings and all you have to
do is stream and everyone says they want
it but push come to shove only ten
thousand people signed up for verified
which had the promise
of money events so I wanted to bring up
this question because I kind of throw it
back at you like we get this a lot but
what we've seen is most people love to
play chess casually they love chess
document for that then some like to play
chess seriously some are professionals
and they're qualified and to do to do
that in big stages and we invest in that
and then some are streamers but not as
many people want to play for prize
events as as they always say they do and
when we created an opportunity for them
to show us that they did they didn't
want to was that a failure on our part
did we not Market verified enough I'm
legitimately asking like how many of you
8 000 people in chat actually knew that
it was going to be only like ten dollars
a year and then you could play in
monthly tournaments that have cash money
on the line and more and like our big
Global championships how many of you
knew that raise your hand I'm asking
because if you knew that and you chose
not to get verified because you decided
to throw us under the Elon Musk Elon
Musk musk Elon Musk bus that's hilarious
because you thought we were just urging
you to get a blue check mark That's not
what it was
it was for events like this and you
didn't do it right so
help me help you here right I you know I
think we will revisit it but for now
uh twitch uh not twitch trim just threw
up a great image which shows we have
under 2 000 under 1800 under 1600 under
1400 and under 1200 prizes right now
every bleeping Wednesday if you're a
streamer so Boondock start streaming and
you literally will get access to cash
prizes in the meantime until we get a
lot more people signing signing a
petition that says a hundred thousand of
you would revisit verified I will bring
back verified if I can get a hundred
thousand people to say you would pay for
verified and it's not just a blue check
mark we are not Elon Musk charging you
for that it actually had purposes with
experiences and access to events with
cash prices if you would actually do
that then we'll bring it back but until
then I love you
thanks for tuning in that's all I got to
say on that
bullet mercenary
when are you organizing the crossfitting
Championships now that is legit
that is legit something that we want to
do because Eric and I are obsessed with
doing physical stuff with chess but we
don't want to get hit in the face
so we are going to do that we actually
are kind of organizing that semi in the
works if you want to actually send Eric
an email I can't give his email out live
but just send Eric a message on
chess.com username Eric he reads them
all the time not like me I never read my
messages don't even send me a message
I'm just going to ghost you but Erica
Eric will get back to you
um and um let him know that um that
you're interested in that yeah by the
way speaking of Arena Kings anybody can
become a community streamer I know that
some people are like ah I'm not going to
stream because they think it's Hikaru or
bust that's not the case
a lot of people stream Arena Kings and a
lot of people stream every day and they
enjoy it and we are investing in that
Community all the time and it's also a
bit of a fair play mechanism the fact
that you stream you put yourself on
camera just share your screen you go
through those rigmarolls not to say
that that's all we do for cheat
detection not even close the algorithms
do the heavy lifting but that's what I
throw back at Boondock Striker and
everyone who wants it is become a
community streamer and get access to
these prize events that we got right
here in front of you right we've got the
uh Arena Kings total price fund right
now can we can we bring that up let's
show them there you go 400 twitch Subs
given out every week God how do they let
me spend so much money when did Eric and
Bryce fall asleep at the wheel
I am spending so much of our money
we're going to spend three and a half
million dollars on prize events this
year and that doesn't include production
or staff or team who gave me access to
the checkbook because I'm giving away
too much money 400 Subs seems
unnecessary
I mean I'm just being honest like we
probably could be giving away 100 Subs a
week and we'd probably have the same
amount of players
streaming
I mean I'm just being honest right why
are we giving 400 Subs away that seems
like someone fell asleep at the wheel
and let Danny get a little too uh frisky
for his own good I don't think things
through I went for the school for kids
who don't think through things good well
too good
so anyway
um yeah we're going to be giving away a
ton of money and and we're and I'm
giving away more all the time so awesome
that's like
400 Subs trim who approved that I
approve that I approved 400 Subs a week
what is wrong with me geez Louise okay
all right last question from e-man
chich Danny who got you into playing
chess
um
it's not a question I'm going to answer
at this time because it involves a life
story that is rated R and I may or may
not be working on bringing that story to
life uh through some form or medium of
some kind so I'm not going to tell you
my whole life story about how I got into
into chess because there's more on that
to come uh but I will say that um I've
been playing show since I was 10 and
enjoyed every every minute of it and I'm
more than grateful uh to be a part of
this community and and where we now I
where I accidentally sit from time to
time helping helping to do amazing
things for chess and uh and thank you
for that question but more on that story
to come
um you don't want the PG version anyway
you want the rated R version and you're
going to get it you Manchester all right
um
step is five you should reach out to
Eric and tell him why you think that
because a lot of people disagree with
you on play
um not being as good as live but I want
I want to agree with you and I want to
know what we can do to fix your
experience if you're experiencing
anything at chess.com play that we used
to have it live that we don't have that
makes me unhappy
so um steves5 send Eric that's his
username e-r-i-k a message and be
specific because he's the most in touch
with product minded Community caring
focused CEO on the planet
I just said it
so that's who that's who Eric is and he
will listen and get back to you
um for those who don't know it I
challenge all other CEOs in the CEO
Gauntlet I think Eric would also chest
box any other CEO in the world if
they're into it I'm just going to do
everything I can to get him in trouble
can we clip that Eric Eric just
challenged every CEO in the world to
chess boxing
um
515 rock climber Danny you're a top
content creator commentator streamer but
you're also an I am how do you balance
all your other stuff
sleep is overrated don't forget I have
four kids and four kids is is honestly
you know probably the dumbest thing I
ever did did I just say that just get it
no it's actually obviously I love
throwing my family under the bus
um
because uh because it's fun but they are
exhausting I I yeah we'll say that I'm I
I have one um that's going to be going
off to college and
um he will be missed
um soon so
Eric versus Elon that is a chess boxing
match that I would pay personal money to
see if we get a community crowdfunded uh
like several million dollars they'd
probably need it because I don't think
Elon has as much money as he says that
guy
you know I think he's I I think what's
going on over there is very confusing I
don't know what's going on we're not
going to go into that right now
um don't clip that he'll cancel me on
Twitter and take away my verified status
that I didn't pay for I assume every day
I log in I'm just going to lose my blue
check mark because I'm not going to pay
and that'll be fun when that happens
um good luck to you Twitter
will chess ever again see the brilliant
commentary of hammer and wrench that
would be a couple of tools a couple of
tools hanging out wouldn't it hammer and
wrench
um all right well I think I think we've
reached a good place we're at Peak
viewership because people love people
love this proverbial bleep people love
this stuff you know when we just let our
hair down and go wild but unless someone
answer asks a great question I think
we're gonna get close to wrapping it up
here because my production team
has worked incredibly hard
recently and long hours and days and up
ahead they've got so much let me let me
um let me just say I mean we're not
we're not checking out just yet but
we've got the feeder world wrapping and
Blitz Championship we've got so much
coming up after that
um so plenty of Chess coming around the
holidays and my team is is working super
hard the team the broadcast team and
everyone the community team
so uh I don't wanna I don't want this to
go on too long so
so last thing
do I need any out-of-the-box ideas no
who do you think would be who do you
think you could be in chess boxing
everyone everyone
that's the right mindset of a chess
boxer
did you watch my video on Twitter
training training with Matt Thomas for
chess boxing go check out
twitter.com Daniel wrench at least for
the next five minutes before the site
crashes and and check out check out my
video that I posted
um
hahaha
I'm not throwing everyone to the bus if
you don't know my sense of humor at ATI
3714 you haven't watched enough shows I
actually I actually am just having
having fun and it's all jokes and good
fun
um
oh this is a good question from KLA
k-l-a-b-u-s-a-n are you planning to
support physical chess boards yes did
you know you can already hook up
dgtess.com for those who like to play
with the dgt board
um
and it we know it's a wave of the future
playing online but with a feel of a
chessboard is something people like
we're going to continue to work on it
some of that Tech is trickier than you
think uh you know just because everyone
kind of has their own proprietary thing
they're doing and so that means we have
to do it a dozen different ways for dgt
and and the Millennium board and the and
the the square off board and now you've
got you know the chess up board that was
on Shark Tank recently congratulations
to the chess up guys right so there's a
lot of stuff to that but we we believe
in it um and so we will do our best to
do it for you
Royal Fork 66 asked 17 questions in a
row and I ignored them I don't know what
the questions were but I wasn't
following chat in real time yet you
might have been asking troll list
questions so maybe that's a you problem
but now that I'm paying attention to
real chat this is your chance
um Danny is being extremely accessible
like this and answering hard questions
is crazy but also extremely awesome
shout out to the entirechess.com
community mods behind the scenes people
host much love thank you bills bills dub
chess I appreciate that comment and I
appreciate your appreciation for it
because it matters a lot
and we we respect the call you know to
action to you know our job is to
innovate grow the game and and to be
transparent and and to be a a beacon uh
for the chess community
we are not uh we are not perfect and we
receive a lot of criticism about how we
do those things and we get that but this
show is a big part of being transparent
showing you what we stand for diving
into tough stuff and reminding you that
our job as the industry leader is going
to be continued to continue to do two
things at our core
innovate product and grow the game that
is the responsibility of every industry
leader in every industry as far as I'm
concerned grow the market and innovate
don't rest on your laurels and that's
what chess.com is trying to do so bills
dub Beals blz dub chess I appreciate
that comment I believe that is what my
company our company is doing
and um and I appreciate the criticism
that has come for many many years on all
the ways that we can and should and
could do it better and I hope we
continue to rise to the occasion so
thank you for that comment and we will
continue to do our job as best we can
um so I drive a Ford Explorer that I
that I really don't like yv and GW I
actually hate it and it's not against
four I actually have driven Ford cars a
lot so Ford don't take that the wrong
way I don't like this particular car
that is what I drive before I swore my
wife drives a Toyota
um Sienna minivan
and uh yeah we like to load up the kids
sometimes when you're going on a long
car trip you need a minivan because you
got that uh you can throw down the back
seats uh and uh really really load and
you'll be surprised how much junk you
could fit in that trunk huh you know
what I'm talking about hey Carla uh
Sienna that's our that's our road trip
car yeah when we're throwing the kiddos
uh in the back and heading on over to
Lambo um anyway all right
d uh what else we got here dear Danny
when is the next Danny versus Nimble
giant chess next next
um next thing for cup
um Jenny want to say you're my favorite
chess commentator I love you thank you
Papa jokester how does chess.com help
grow chess for lower income folks who
don't have money to travel to Germans or
for an online membership helps grow the
game I agree well I think there's a lot
of things you can do with a basic
membership on chess.com you can you
probably have access to a local club
that meets and doesn't necessarily
charge money for it I think there are a
lot of opportunities to do that right
and you know our our main focus has been
to add value for the things that we are
asking premium members to support I also
think we we try to at least keep the
inspiration and love you have to play
the game alive with these shows so I
would say papa jokester is that
obviously there are features that are
only available to premium right and we
can't control everyone's travel budget
to tournaments but everything we bring
you in terms of a show
um you do watch a few ads from time to
time but you do that everywhere else
from YouTube to Hulu and everywhere else
right what we're bringing you here is
the biggest events with the best players
with the biggest prize money and the
best commentators and we do it for free
we're not not locking it down over over
a pay wall and I would say that our
biggest investment that helps to serve
and grow the game Papa jokester is what
you see right now on Twitch and what
we're doing to invest from a Content
perspective so if I was to really speak
directly to that I understand it's a bit
of a challenging question I would say
that we're putting more into the game
from a content and entertainment and to
inspire and bring the joy of learning to
people around the world for free than
anybody in the world times 10 and that's
what we're going to continue to do and
obviously we do appreciate our premium
members and we appreciate the
subscribers because they're kind of
helping to make it possible
um
and our content kind of speaks for
itself right and that's kind of what we
do so I think on that note
Danny's going to be out
I love you guys I love you guys I love
you I say I love you and people go like
oh you can't know all of us in love I
actually do know all of you I know where
you live what you what you eat where you
sleep
I'm like Santa Claus
for those who celebrate that
now we uh
uh I posted an image to my Instagram
yesterday that my my daughter like drew
a thing that said dads are like Santa
Claus except in no way like Santa Claus
but that's it Santa Claus you know
that's what we're doing
um we're uh we're gonna we're gonna be
out right there and I'm gonna wish
everybody Happy Holidays regardless of
what you celebrate
um around the world thank you so much
for being here thank you so much for
your support I'm gonna take one last
deep breath this has been a long time
coming
um this has been a bit of a uh as I said
throwing the ring into Mordor Frodo
style it is done when it comes to the
acquisition of PMG
um there's been a lot more to it than
people think and a lot of hard work so
to everyone who kind of brought that to
be possible we genuinely believe that
there's so much good stuff ahead for the
years of Chess we are going to be
talking in 10 years about remember when
they thought six million daily active
users was a big deal and now we're where
we are right and we believe that's where
we're headed
we hope you guys are all along the uh
along with us for that Journey
um and um for the entire company of
chess.com which is now one with the play
Magnus group for all of us in the chess
family and the crew that works super
hard I want to say thank you for being
here thank you for watching thank you
for your support and I cannot wait to
see you on the other side of the
calendar year because yours truly will
not be on TV again until we are in the
year of 2023 so my best wishes to all of
you enjoy the holiday season be safe for
everyone this has been the state of
chess.com I'm Danny wrench and thank you
for watching
[Music]
do you like
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
three two one
[Music]
check it out